all right hey what's going on it's Bill
Byrne it's time for another wonderful
edition of the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
ah
I'm just checking in on you
checking in to see how your week's going
if you're not just listening to audio if
you're watching the video
you know I'm not I'm not this kind of
vain person I don't just film myself for
the sake of showing you my bald freckled
Charlie Brown head not at all that means
I have a special guest somebody that I
admire somebody that I'm a huge fan of
I've known this guy forever we have the
one and only the legendary Mr Jim
Florentine Jim how you doing thanks for
having me Bill I appreciate it yeah Jim
has a new special let's get the promo
out of the way he's got a new special
called bite the bullet on Amazon Prime
by the way you see that guy's [ __ ]
yacht unbelievable uh and he has a new
uh the guy runs Amazon yeah uh the new
uh terrorizing telemarketers volume
sever volume seven volume seven wherever
music is available and he also has a
wonderful show on Ozzie's Boneyard
called
um yeah it's just Jim florentine's show
it used to be metal midgets but yeah you
can't say midgets anymore all right yes
it's like a relationship with this woke
[ __ ] you got to meet him halfway yeah
you know what I mean like you can't just
go no I'm not doing anything so you kind
of have to you can meet him a little
just a little yeah
just not little in a bad way like like
yeah you gotta get like five steps I'll
go five steps before I was like nope
I'll give you five stars all right I
have to tell you something I gotta admit
something here with your your
terrorizing telemarketers and the [ __ ]
that you do dude it's so [ __ ] awkward
I have to like shut it off sometimes
like there was a video on the internet
where he goes into a restaurant and
before like they even come over you're
gonna ask for more pepper yeah and it's
just like you tell everybody at the
table they just let you know it's just
gonna get really awkward and the guy
starts putting pepper on this [ __ ]
piece of fish and he go they go through
like four pepper Mills it gets to the
point you can't even see the fish
anymore and you're like yeah I still I I
still need more pepper and you never
break and there's this [ __ ] mountain
of pepper on this fish and you think the
joke's over and he turns it over to do
the other side yeah go get you start on
this side now I mean it was I can't
believe they didn't just at some point
just say we're not doing this it was
weird I don't know it was it was in
Hell's Kitchen at some restaurant like
the Spanish restaurant we went in we
just figured we're gonna do it and then
it got to the point where they ran out
of pepper Mills because there's no so
they were like chop it up in the back
and they were just putting it in bowls
and coming out with these little bowls
and just dumping it on and I had my
hidden camera guys this little guy with
a pen behind us here I go go in the
kitchen because we heard him pounding in
there go see what's going on and he go
just say you were looking for the
bathroom and he got the shot and then
pounded he's like yeah well the guy
likes a lot of pepper I don't know we're
just gonna put it in balls and they were
coming out and dumping it on
but I said I go it's going to ruin the
joke if everyone starts talking at the
table the awkwardness of everybody is
sitting there minding their own business
and complete science because you just
hear the peppers how do you like
keep a straight face because I've been
lying to women for years you know when
you lie and you don't [ __ ] break
character it's easy
if it's a good lie if it's [ __ ]
ridiculous I don't know I had that
uncounty ability of just being dry and
just a stone face
once in a while I'll break you know once
in a while if the camera's on I'll break
but usually I could I can whatever
happened on The Carol Burnett Show back
in the day you were the absolute
opposite where they used to just start
cracking up there in the middle you like
that other one that you you and uh I
don't know who else was on that thing
um when you hold on a second I got let
me put my brother on oh yeah Jameson
yeah he's my um yeah we just hand the
phone back and forth yeah this lady some
sales person you're going to buy
something in redis she would try to like
close the deal you'd go hang on let me
put my brother on the phone and then he
would talk and get her all set hang on
let me put my brother on the phone and
you guys must have done that like 40
[ __ ] times I'll tell you that's one
time I did break because it was a phone
it was a telemarketer call and me and
Don were looking at each other like this
far away from me and you and like hold
on let me probably run on the phone and
hand it back and I started laughing
because I looked at him laughing so and
we I hung up and I'm like what the I go
you broke first because no you did we're
arguing I go you can't [ __ ] break
character so when someone called back we
were back to back we stood back to back
so we couldn't look at each other we're
passing the phone behind our shoulder
like this because I couldn't look him in
the face he couldn't look at me and
that's how we did that call and I could
feel his back shaking and I'm shaking
but I wouldn't look at him because I was
going to break and that's how we now
that call him like the second one dude I
mean that thing is a masterpiece like I
was
I've played that for so many goddamn
people hold you can look that one up
holding my brother on the phone I mean I
lost count of how many times you guys
say and the people just [ __ ] just
hanging in there
um I don't know your ability
like to do that stuff you were like a
master and what I always love is it
starts with the most simplest idea and
then the levels of Comedy become so
complex
and to the point like this sometimes I
just stop laughing because I'm just
appreciating like the depth of the
comedy and like how are these guys not
[ __ ] laugh you know I was a big fan
of that Versi me and Paul verzi like he
sends me your [ __ ] I'll send him uh some
[ __ ] and we just start [ __ ] cracking
up laughing it's like the amount of
times people like back in the day before
he started you know blowing up and
selling tickets and [ __ ] we would be on
the road and we would just put you and
Don Jameson on and just sit there
[ __ ] crying laughing and then like
afterwards like the second level of
laughs was talking about like how do you
not laugh through that and then quoting
all the lines so
um I you know totally recommend the new
terrorizing telemarketers volume seven
dude there's a track on there it's
called fiance it's 18 minutes and one
second long where this guy's calling
about to get me some mortgage
and I go I I just I go can you hold on I
got food coming at the door I got a food
order he goes yeah and Don Jameson picks
up he's like hello he's like yeah he
goes uh he goes you just talked to my
roommate he goes because I told the guy
yeah I'm getting married I need a
mortgage I'm getting married in two
weeks I go let me oh I just knock on the
door I said done but yeah he said did he
tell you he's getting married and the
mortgage guy goes yeah he told me he's
getting married in two weeks he's
looking for a mortgage yeah I guess I I
don't know if he should marry her and
the guy's like yeah look I don't know I
don't know I'm just trying to sell the
guy mortgage I'm just letting you know
I'm his roommate and uh I had an affair
with like a week ago and
and the guy's like whoa he's like yeah
and he's like the Don's like listen I
don't know how to tell him and and all
of a sudden he goes oh he's coming back
now he goes can you tell him for me
please all right here hold the phone
here and I get back on her hello are you
just talking my roommate he goes yeah
yeah like okay cool and then he goes
back into his pitch he doesn't want to
tell me and then Don picks up I go alone
because yeah he goes uh I go I'm on the
phone he goes okay did he tell you I go
tell you tell me what
he goes he didn't tell you I go what
were you supposed to tell me sir and he
breaks it to me oh my God you gotta hear
it it's 18 minutes long this guy's
trying to counsel us and we're just I'm
like you know Don's like well she was
really hot what was I gonna do and the
guy said you don't do that to you your
roommate he's like she's like a nine and
a half you gotta how do you [ __ ] come
and you guys were like right next to
each other and you're not not breaking
at one point he goes I'll do it I really
thought this was a prank call obviously
it's not and he's counseling us like a
therapist like why would you do that to
your friend I'm like should I still be
his friend he's like no and Don's like
can I still come to the wedding it's you
got it the level of it it's the most
uncomfortable
I call of all time how the [ __ ] do
people because I remember with like The
Jerky Boys after a while like Frank
Rizzo's voice was so fun that character
was so iconic I I think it became
difficult for them to get people
where your voice I mean I think is so
distinguishable but you still you got
like that underground thing still that
you can still get like I would just
think that they would be like that's
[ __ ] Jim Florentine one out of ten
calls I'll get that I know who this is
dude I'm a fan oh I'm like I don't know
what you're talking about and I get
busted on my guy I'd hang up they got me
I saw one out of ten they'll recognize
my voice all right but other than that
they don't know I don't know it's just
you know people random calling I guess I
know my voice so it's great dude you're
the only guy that has that voice you've
been [ __ ] with these people for 20
years easily for 20 years I've been
doing it I remember we were editing the
new album my kitchen and my son who's 12
and his friend was always like his son
is 12. yeah he's like you guys are so
immature that was coming from 12 year
olds for guys in their 50s I'm like
we're on to something yeah he just
turned 12. let me when did like you must
have been just doing this just for the
[ __ ] of it when you were a kid I was
because I was always grounded you know I
was always in trouble I went to Catholic
school it's just causing problems
constantly all right for younger people
out there and before there was like star
69 used to be able to do that and you
could like trace a call like you used to
just call up and prank call people was
just like something you did when your
parents weren't home and uh like there
was people that had it like to like an
art form and my thing was I would always
always start laughing I just was I don't
know what it was like I just thought
[ __ ] with people was the funniest
thing ever and like you know if we were
in school and we started [ __ ] with
the teacher I was always the guy that
just started cracking up laughing I was
just like my favorite thing ever
um like as much as I made people laugh I
wasn't really a Class Clown because I
always thought to get your stripes as a
Class Clown you had to have two things
the ability to keep a straight face and
also not give a [ __ ] if you got sent
down the office like you just didn't
give a [ __ ] yeah and like I was a funny
guy in class but I wasn't like to the
level of these like you know these guys
always getting detention and getting
suspended like my parents would have
killed so I kind of stayed
in my lane and when the first time I
started hearing recordings Crank Yankers
and all that stuff I was like oh this
guy
this guy's like you know like I remember
like yes as a Class Clown when you went
to summer school that was almost like an
All-Star team of class clowns and [ __ ]
up so it always sounds like man I
thought it was funny this is like the
big leagues like these guys are like
giving the teacher [ __ ] and a few of
them like cursed in class and I was just
like whoa like what is this it was all
of a sudden like oh my God this is 100
mile an hour fastball I'm not ready for
this so I kind of like
you know I kind of kept my mouth shut I
would always be laughing and [ __ ] but
like uh I I couldn't hang with like the
big dogs or something like that so
that's what I love about the stuff that
you do
um is it reminds me of all that and I
can totally see like like who you are so
I also want to promote uh your special
here before I get too and deep with this
other stuff uh bite the bullet
on Amazon where did you shoot it and uh
Fairfield theater in Fairfield
Connecticut oh that's great yeah so like
700 seat theater it looks amazing
perfect shot it for super cheap don't
tell Amazon it's super cheap well they
do you know yeah whatever but right yeah
so the two shows that I basically you
know got attendance pay for the special
which is insane which you know eight
years ago I shot one for you know
almost 200 Grand all right they finally
made some backyard equipment for the the
star of a spaghetti western
solo stove huh are you that bad boy
James Dean character that comes in town
and wants to feel warm by a fire but
doesn't want to have to [ __ ] strike a
couple of pieces of Flint together
uh uh solo stop you know there's
something special about fall that brings
us closer together and with the
smokeless fire pit from solo stove
creating those moments is easier than
ever enjoy all the warmth and comfort of
a fire pit plus portability quick setup
and cleaning and best of all no smoke
summer make uh summer may get all the
excitement but nothing beats The Great
Outdoors during the fall make the most
of your outdoor time this season with
solo stoves smokeless portable fire pits
that are easy to set up and clean and
right now it's October right [ __ ]
Halloween's coming up you make some
pumpkin bread you take your wife out
there you get the fire going she eats a
couple of sweets maybe she wants an
eclair for [ __ ] dessert if you know
what I mean
um
why is your dick in e-clear because
there's cream inside oh Jesus uh
make most of your outdoor time this
season with solo stove smokeless
portable fire pits that makes it very
easy to clean and set up upgrade your
backyard with the solo Stove fire pit
and create story worthy moments without
Fireside fumes stainless steel
conduction construction designed to
regulate airflow and burn more more
efficiently so little smoke you'll
wonder if there's even a fire uh solo
Stove fire pits are brilliantly
engineered be helpful if I could [ __ ]
read huh to be easy to use and they're
built to last prepare for your best
Outdoor Memories yet and save big during
the solo stove uh fall event plus use
promo code Burr at solostove.com for an
extra ten dollars off and if you act now
they'll add a little person in there to
light it for you
um that solos
solo stuff.com I don't know why I
picture them coming in with a little Top
Hat promo just it you know like we know
when they send a ship off when they
[ __ ] crash the uh the champagne
bottle they have a little person come in
with a little [ __ ] flick and he
lights it you know and then sing
something from the Gershwin catalog uh
that's solostove.com promo code bird for
ten dollars off on the top of the fall
on top of the Fall event deals hurry the
fall ends November 10th uh it's a great
thing to get if you watch college
football outside with your flat screen
as the months start to get a little
colder well I think uh I don't know I
think the stuff that you're doing like
you have like just like three things
that I love prank calls stand-up comedy
and then you show on Ozzie's Boneyard
and I always like I like I'm you know
I'm an 80s kid so I'm always putting
that on and I just recently saw
uh there's a new documentary on Randy
Rhodes which I find just to be uh his
whole career and the whole uh
guitar players seen out here in the
valley in the 70s and 80s to just be
like just this never-ending like
fascinating story and what this
documentary communicated really it
showed how long he was in Randy was in
um Quiet Riot uh before he got the gig
with Ozzy and uh and how
like how Randy was like the the shredder
in Burbank and Eddie Van Halen was like
the shredder in Pasadena and like one
time they actually did a show together
I'm just thinking like I cannot [ __ ]
believe
that like two guys that good at guitar
were like that would be like you know
where I grew up was a big hockey town
and it would be like yeah Two Towns over
is this guy Wayne Gretzky and in my town
we got this guy Mario Lemieux and you
would watch them unfamous like going up
going against each other
um like that whole scene out here
um
I really found fascinating I was telling
you before that uh
um Randy's mother started this School of
Music out here in 1949 and it's still
here in the valley I drove by it was
like and like Randy took like lessons
there and stuff like
like the um I don't know if that would
be a good thing for you to talk about on
like your show but I was know you've
been to a bunch of shows so I was
wondering did you ever see Randy did you
ever see us five times I met Randy like
three times how
I'm just I'm a lucky [ __ ] because I had
two older brothers that were like five
and six years older than me so they
would just take me to concerts my
parents will let them take me so I was
going to concerts when I was like 11 10
years old 14. so you must have gone in
he only toured with Ozzy
81-82 I saw the show three nights in a
row when I was living down in Florida at
the time and I would wait outside the
venue I cut school and I went to venue
it was like three miles from my house I
walked at a venue and waited outside for
for us for the band to come I'd like two
in the afternoon so Randy pulls up in a
taxi I start talking him for like 10
minutes before he goes in the venue I go
hey man can I go see the sound check I
was at the show last night he's like oh
man I'd like to go yeah but I can then
they did a record store appearance I met
Randy wait wait wait wait what was he
like he was cool he was just a tiny I
weighed like 100 pounds he was like five
to maybe a hundred pounds I mean almost
like anorexic well you see Aussie
[ __ ] pictures
yeah I mean super tight but super nice
you know and I met him at a
a record store appearance Ozzie would
always have the band there to sign so I
got his autograph I got a picture with
not a Mac and actually in the picture
when I go Randy can I get a picture and
he's like this I'll show you the picture
after the show he's got his thumbs up
and I took it he was behind the counter
I gave it to Rudy sarso I'm friends with
Rudy he's like dude I never saw this
picture again it was on my freaking
camera roll but um she's like the nicest
guy I met him a couple of times Rudy's
the best and that was like Randy's best
friend and that's Randy got Rudy in the
band at one point but uh yeah so I wound
up seeing him five times I was in the
front row for like three of them because
it was General Mission back then Ozzie
wasn't a big draw when he was when he
had blizzard of Oz when that first came
out when Randy was in the band he was
doing like 1500 people thousand people
because he was probably considered like
a dinosaur where like that was before
like you got to think like the Rolling
Stones as much as they were considered
old they were like in their late 30s
when when he started his his solo
project
um
and like he was probably considered like
sabba's considered a 60s or 70s band 70s
70 to 78 pretty much they were but no he
was 31 and they considered him washed up
when Sabbath threw him out in like 79.
because you were back then right he
really thought he was washed up everyone
like they started remember I remember 20
years ago every comic doing jokes about
the Rolling Stones being old and wearing
diapers on stage or whatever like and
they're still going strong now they're
not even old anymore like no one makes
that joke anymore Matt Jagger's still
out there at 80 freaking working a
stadium like a maniac yeah well that's
what I always felt with like Aerosmith
like Aerosmith was never viewed as old
because the stones were always 10 years
older than them so they got to be like
no one ever said Aerosmith's getting
older I feel until like now when they
they you know hits like
like I know Stephen Tyler's maybe 70 or
72 but like I have some friends of mine
just saw them in Fenway Park I'm like
dude they sound [ __ ] better than ever
like absolutely destroyed I was just
like [ __ ] I would have loved to have
seen them at Fenway because I saw them
at the Boston Garden
um
in 1989 December 31st 1989 like the last
day of the 80s on the pump tour and uh
Skid Row opened up with Sebastian Bach
just [ __ ] animal oh my God oh my God and
that guy uh snake yeah snake Sabo oh my
God like they just [ __ ] ripped and
then Aerosmith came out
and they had this really cool like
Boston like subway thing that they kind
of came out I vaguely remember that
and uh we did the countdown with them
like I spent New Years with [ __ ] you
know uh with with Aerosmith at the
Boston Garden I was just like I I
thought I was like the luckiest kid in
the world and I mean dude I was like
[ __ ] you know they they played at one
end of the arena and I was like sort of
mid-level like behind what the
goaltender would be at the opposite end
of the ice okay and uh I still remember
that show was just [ __ ]
like amazing and I think that you know
all of those bands like Blaze the trail
for like bands like you two like why
can't they keep going why can't all
these other people just kind of keep
going or like guys like Bob Dylan and
all of that why can't they why can't you
just keep going I remember Keith
Richards had like the best
um answer
when somebody said like well how long
are you gonna do this
and he just laughed he goes with me
because I'm a musician he goes this is
what I do and he's like I would do this
in front of five people he goes I love
it and the guy goes you love it that
much huh he goes oh yeah he goes he goes
when I open a guitar case and I just
smell the guitar he goes I want to crawl
in and close the lid I was just like wow
and he just said it with like such a
love and passion in this big smile on
his face and it was just like how do you
[ __ ] with that like you like at that
point you're just mad because a guy
found what he loved and he said sure
find himself I I
um
I don't know that's um it's almost like
stand up like you know I always thought
like when I'm in my early four days ago
maybe I'll do it till like maybe early
50s and then I'm done and then I'm now
in my 50s I'm like I love I love it even
more like I don't even know when I
thought I was gonna stop at some point I
could see myself if some Club will take
me at 73 74 still performing and I'll
tell you what else am I going to do I I
have a more appreciate it now than ever
right and I'll tell you the guys
that don't enjoy it there's just like
the guys that resent the younger people
coming up like there's nothing that's
gonna suck your [ __ ] life force like
it's like dude there's there's nothing
you can do about that I love watching
new Comics come up and coming and
breaking and stuff like that I never got
jealous even back in the day when we
started I was like there's gonna be 500
channels everyone there's room for
everyone I remember when Sue Costello
got her first deal she was at that
sitcom for a little about Fox all the
New York Comics are like oh man well she
doesn't deserve it I go they weren't
looking for you they were looking for a
[ __ ] female yeah that's so funny like
a guy [ __ ] bitching about her like oh
are they gonna give it to you give it up
to you and Sue when they gave it to Sue
when they did decided okay I remember
that I'm like who cares they weren't
looking for you they were looking for
her do you know my and I'll tell you too
like my goal in this [ __ ] business
was to be in at the improvs and sell
them out that's all that like that's how
like the biggest comics when we started
out that's all they were doing there was
a few guys like Cosby and Carlin and uh
maybe Steven Wright I'm trying to think
that the people like I remember like
Carlin would play uh
ah [ __ ] what's that gig up in New
Hampshire
it's this classic old rock venue that
like Zeppelin played um Old Orchard
Beach maybe and there was uh there's
just this venue up this great [ __ ]
venue there's like no air conditioning I
would always get booked there in the
summertime to be sweating just feeling
like a real [ __ ] like Showbiz guy
like you're up to James Brown sweating
like that even though you're just
standing there telling [ __ ] jokes uh the
only reason why you're sweating is
because there's no AC but like there was
a few like I remember like I remember
doing like uh this guy Bob Marley had
some uh hell room up there like the
second floor of a bar that you do stand
up and uh we were both I remember
talking to him about that like man
Colin's down the streets playing in
front of 700 [ __ ] people can you
imagine that and dude he just comes in
and he does New Hampshire and then he
[ __ ] leaves it was just like there
was nobody like that and then there was
like TV stars
like
like all those uh In Living Color guys
yeah like when they came to town they
played the comet they did six shows sold
out at uh at uh at Faneuil Hall at the
comedy connection it was just like holy
[ __ ] oh like Brian Regan would come in
and do the club like that whole doing
theaters
like that was like some Steve Martin bow
and arrow through your head like like
right that was rare you're right yeah
like he had like when he had the white
suit with the bow and arrow and the
banjo and it was just like oh my God but
but like you know or dice they would
like there was these occasional like
Eddie Murphy just juggernauts but Eddie
had stopped too yep at that point uh who
knew he wasn't gonna uh come back but um
that just there just wasn't that when we
were uh
when we were coming up so I don't know
what my [ __ ] point is I just remember
I remember a lot of comics that were
around that were around for a while the
veterans the headliners we were coming
up they were all jealous of us they they
were so miserable because we were up in
common and stuff like that that and you
still those guys that are still around
they're still good they're still jealous
after all these years I'm like who cares
let that [ __ ] they would get so mad that
we started doing well because me and
Norton were good friends we were
roommates and Norton was killing in
front of them like take that joke out
take that you're too dirty these [ __ ]
Jersey guys they're filthy we get a lot
[ __ ] so and they were trying to take our
weapon so and be mad I'm like hey if
you're in a headline you got a [ __ ]
deal what's whatever's on in front of
you
I would that's why I never told the
comic what to do before me I don't care
if you do the [ __ ] arms in front of
me whatever you got to do I go I got to
do my job so like I never worried about
because all he's had what are the arms
remember they could get remembered a guy
we get up on stage some someone from the
crowd get behind him with the arms he
goes so I'm driving oh and I'm smoking a
joint and they're behind them holding
them oh yeah oh yeah it would kill oh
yeah oh I love that bit I know but every
comic would close with it and you
couldn't follow it I I had a scratch my
crotch and it had a girl you know oh and
she would go close to it or whatever and
the crowd would go nuts oh my God and it
was like nine Headliners when I first
started I had that you know the closing
bit as the arms
all right
and then we got mad when guys are doing
original material and killing you know
before him but like I said I don't get
jealous I love that all these uh
becoming Congress are doing well no you
want somebody to make you [ __ ] work
and then there's another thing too is
like you just have to understand like
every generation has to have their bands
their Comedians and all that just be
[ __ ] cool
[ __ ] help them out and then you know
what you'll get to play their
grandfather in something and you'll
you'll you'll get sag Insurance in your
60s who gives a [ __ ] none of us have
real jobs these aren't real jobs we're
just [ __ ] around here I always tell
people I go if you're not a dick in this
business and if you're in it long enough
you're going to get stuff just don't be
a dick there's gonna be a few people
you're gonna tell off but as long as
you're not dead people you know what
yeah I'm gonna give that guy something
yeah he's a good dude whatever you don't
have to do what you do where you you've
you're uh one of those guys like most of
my friends I feel like all of us like
created opportunities by like nobody
said hey you should you should record
these prank phone calls you just started
doing it you started putting them out
and all that stuff I was just had you
know Joe list on here and we were just
talking about that as far as like uh you
know
he had an idea for a movie and he got
together with Louis CK and they sat down
they wrote it they cast it they shot it
and they [ __ ] put it out and
like that's I don't know and I mean
unless you look like [ __ ] Brad Pitt
and what comic does oh dude who does I
mean that guy's like pushing 60 he still
has abs he's still [ __ ] gorgeous my
wife would walk away from me in front in
front of me if she [ __ ] saw him and
it's just like you know those people
um it is nothing too is you know I've
done a couple of movies now and I've
I've worked with the few of those
[ __ ] people that I like that and I'm
telling you dude they're just another
level of good looking and you you're
looking at body parts you never look at
like I remember Sandra Bullock I
remember her forearms were beautiful
really like she was just holding the
dress those are the most beautiful
forearms I've ever seen in my life it's
just like they're just different they're
just like movie stars that's been like
uh I did a table read one time with oh
my God I just I just spaced on his name
the guy from [ __ ] uh Knight Rider uh
Hasselhoff David Hasselhoff I did I did
a table read I was maybe going to get a
part and then I did the table read
they're like yeah [ __ ] this guy dude I
said next that guy dude one of the top
10 most beautiful looking guys right on
like if you couldn't draw a better
looking guy right like he's got like the
[ __ ] the curly hair that just doesn't
thin at all he's got the [ __ ] jaw
with the little dimple in it the [ __ ]
chest he was tall
he smelled good the guy was just like I
was just like this guy is like just like
chiseled it's just like I totally get
why this guy's here why this guy's keep
keeps [ __ ] working and then like you
just feel like this troll like you
should be dragging a leg when you when
you come in so I always tell people like
listen man
you know if you don't look
like these people and then you know
what's funny about them though is after
they're in it for a while
like they still have to like what I love
about Brad Pitt is he could have he
could have just been the good looking
guy and like he's like one of the like
low-key one of the best [ __ ]
character actors out there like he's
like uh
um I'm trying to think like dude that
that uh what was that terror attack I'm
so bad remember the names True Romance
uh when he plays the stone or on the
couch yep when he played the serial
killer and with the one the David
Duchovny when he played in seven yeah
when he played in
um
um the Nazi killer one the Tarantino one
yeah uh whatever [ __ ] that one was
called uh [ __ ] you Rudolph Hess what was
it called
Inglorious man and glorious bastards
react like he could speak German and
then he couldn't he was [ __ ]
hilarious uh those uh Lock Stock and
seven smokers
11. snatch sorry that said yes not yeah
yeah no he could easily want the
romantic comedy route and did 10 of them
those cookie cutter ones because he's a
good look dude he never went that way
and then I think uh that um uh uh Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood him and
Leonardo DiCaprio like like that's like
my favorite performances and I love all
of this [ __ ] but like what I watched the
movie I saw that three [ __ ] times I
just once kept going to the movies I
just [ __ ] love this movie I love the
cars I love the time yeah yeah I love
that Tarantino reduced you know Manson
family had like this Aura bottom and
Tarantino reduced him to a bunch of
hippie [ __ ] who didn't want to get
a job I know I know and I'm saying I was
looking back I'm like yeah that's kind
of like what they were and they really
were stupid and they followed this
[ __ ] idiot and then they went out and
they actually destroyed
beautiful people's lives and this woman
who had this whole career ahead of her
and like you know I'm a dumb guy so it
took me like three times of watching it
to like really [ __ ] see his message
in that and I thought like uh in one of
my favorite things in that I got to see
it for a fourth time is I don't think
anybody says hippie without saying
[ __ ] hippie it's always [ __ ] hip
he's a bunch of [ __ ] hippies yeah but
he's got the [ __ ] margarita mix oh
yeah yeah he's sipping on he's like
I thought you [ __ ] goddamn hippies or
whatever I was just like
I lied my I absolutely uh there's so
many subtle uh like the humor in his
movies is incredible but uh let's uh
let's talk what about in Pulp Fiction
when um
Harvey Keitel comes over as the cleaner
because I shot the guy in the back seat
and Tarantino's freaking out hey my
wife's gonna be home a little bit you
got coffee I got coffee and he gives a
cup that uh to hobby cartel however he
goes
[Laughter]
no that's that [ __ ] that like
that that stuff there's so much humor in
like like he has really dark [ __ ] in his
movies but they're [ __ ] hilarious
like I actually still to this day I
think one of the greatest like uh black
comedy dark comedy whatever you call it
uh Gallows humor is is uh is Good Fellas
like the [ __ ] that they're doing these
guys are like sociopaths and they were
[ __ ] hilarious my I watched my son
watched it the last week for the first
time he said it was the greatest movie
he's ever seen and he's 12. he because I
didn't appreciate the humor because he's
laughing at Pesci the [ __ ] that he was
saying he's dying laughing I'm like you
know what I didn't even like I know it
was funny but I'm just like and he's
just talking because he knows him from
uh what was the movie he did with uh
what the [ __ ] what is the lawyer oh my
cousin visits yeah my cousin Vinnie so
he loves to pass you from that and I go
you got to see my good photos I'm
showing the mob movies but I I he's
dying at the at the humor and it's so
[ __ ] funny you know it's underrated
everybody who quotes that movie what's
[ __ ] underrated is when uh Ray Leota
rest his soul when Henry Hill stands up
uh Karen for that second date and
Pesci's acting like he gives a [ __ ] no
he really liked you man you should call
him you know it just completely not
giving a [ __ ] and uh and then the way
they played that scene when she comes up
like who's screaming at him and like how
all the guys are like laughing like oh
[ __ ] above on you see him he's kind of
smiling and like the way Ray Liotta
played that where you could see he's
attracted by like her fire and her
passion and that she comes up and she
doesn't take any [ __ ] and all of a
sudden he sees her in like this like and
all of that that's not in the dialogue
it's all like the look on his face
um yeah man it's a it's like a [ __ ]
Masterpiece so
um that was great when he shoots uh you
know Junior he's like hey you killed
them I'm a good shot right I'm a good
shot what do you want from him a good
shot yeah
I could never dig a hole before I'll
take a whole one I'm a good shot I'm a
good shot he just oh and then one of the
Frankie carbon he's like nice game nice
[ __ ] game yeah like like somebody
like somebody brought up politics or
something it's like he literally just
murdered a guy yeah nice game nice
[ __ ] game
um do you have any uh stand up dates or
anything like that that we can promote
here so I don't know I don't forget to
do this because I'm happily looking yeah
I'll be at the Funny Bone of Omaha
Nebraska October 14 15. all right I love
I love Nebraska it's great and uh hyenas
Comedy Club Fort Worth Texas November
like fourth and fifth all dates for my
website Jim florentine.com all right
good deal well you've got uh I I just
don't feel like I asked you enough music
questions tell me we started talking
online well Randy Rhodes yeah I mean I
you know I it's what else who else did
you see with your older boy when was
your first concert and who did you see I
saw black I saw Van Halen on for Black
Sabbath on their first tour Van Halen at
Madison Square Garden [ __ ] where was
I you're not that much older no I'm not
but I told you my older brothers my
parents would let them take me I saw
Bonsai did they blow Sabbath off the
stage no they didn't and that's a big
myth because the the album I I even
asked Naomi on That Metal Show one time
like did they blow you off stage he goes
no they didn't their album was only out
for about four months I think it came
out in like March this was August but
there's only two songs playing on the
radio you really got me and Running With
the Devil but weren't you also like you
know when Eddie broke it was like this
guy sounded like he was from another
planet no we we got the album I mean my
brothers because like it was this band
of opening Van Halen let's go buy their
album to see what they sound like oh
this this band's good but you know how
they used to do it back in the day the
the headliner band would [ __ ] with the
opening band they'd mess with their
sound yeah they give them like 30
minutes or 35 minutes and they would
have a little part at a stage and
everybody was so stoned there because
that was when everybody just passed a
joint down the road when everyone was
just smoking it was all Sabbath pre-comb
yeah it was just that was the first time
I smoked three monkey pox that was the
first time I smoked weed at 14. oh you
wanted to fit in they were passing a
joint and it came to me and my brothers
they looked at me like can I and he's
like yeah go ahead and that was the
first time I smoked weed at that show
did you get high did you oh yeah I was
[ __ ] up but it didn't hit me till like
three songs like three songs left a
Sabbath which is good I didn't get high
right away [ __ ] guy you probably in
that crowd shot from The Song Remains
the Same you know what Madison Square
Garden when they put the lights up and
it's just nothing but hair oh yeah yeah
because you know back then people didn't
know how to grow their hair out they
used to just let it go they wouldn't
layer it so it'd be like it'd have to
make it go down to here it'd have to
come out like this far like it just
looked like a bunch of Muppets who else
did you see I saw Bon Scott twice with
AC DC on what tours let there be rocking
Highway to Hell No One Highway to Hell
or two times a Def Leppard open for him
on through the night their first record
I saw it so they had that Pete what's
his face P Willis oh my God he was in
the band and and uh I would have hell
just came or maybe it just came out or
idea it came out and then I saw AC DC
home for Ted Nugent in 1979 at the
Garden which Joey Diaz was at the same
show I didn't know
and they said and bond brought you know
Angus out on his shoulders through the
whole crowd that was what highway to
hell just came out like that week so I
saw uh Bond twice and they opened for
who they open for Ted Nugent at the
Garden and then they did the place I was
gonna ask if they blew him off stage but
I know the answer to that no no because
I mean Ted Nugent it's just fun yeah Ted
and his prime was unbelievable and ACC
was just breaking and the states went
Highway to Hell like they didn't have
they that was the album that put him
over the top started to put him over
stop Back Back in Black put him in
arenas but even Highway to Hell it took
a little time for that album to hit and
how would a hellstalk and played on the
radio at the time before that they
didn't have any hits all right I bought
a great uh album of this they got one
live at The Paradise in Boston which is
the first place like uh when when bands
would come to Boston sting played there
in the late the late 70s Youtube played
there and uh AC DC dude it was this
little [ __ ] club it's always with bun
yeah oh yeah it's with Bond and it's a
live album it's just [ __ ] great man
they just sound amazing and then it's
sort of you know it's a bootleg but like
legal now yeah and uh well it was it was
the basically the WBC and the radio
station recording I think and then
somehow they worked it out so what they
have for the cover of it is
um outtakes from the Highway to Hell
banned photo album oh really yeah so
um I forget when they took it uh when uh
when it was recorded I want to say it
was before was there anything on Highway
to Hell on the on the live recording
I'll have to go back and look at it
because my stereo's on the fritz
I moved the stereo and I bent the
[ __ ] the prong for the wire so I got
I haven't been listening to anything uh
lately but um all right so here did you
know that wait Dirty Deeds Done Dirt
Cheap that album they didn't even put it
out in the states I didn't think it was
any good it was only available in Europe
until Back in Black hit that's when they
put the album yeah and I remember not
understanding like why it was out in 70.
I had the copy from 1978 my brothers had
it when I was a kid so we already had
the bootleg copy of it well it wasn't an
album and it was in Australia it was on
like that was part of the high voltage
they had a TNT album data TNT they also
had a Dirty Deeds but Bond had a big
like a character of them would have been
when I went down to Australia I bought
all of those and for all my siblings on
CD yeah it's like a really bad drawing
too yeah it was hard gaming with the
stripe thing and yeah and he's you know
he's singing like this and it's just
like totally rubber yeah like really
like all right whose sister uh like Drew
this [ __ ] who's in like art school
um well unfortunately I gotta go back uh
finish up in this [ __ ] edit thing I'm
almost done here
um with but dude I gotta tell you uh
like I'm such a huge fan of you over the
years you're one of the best guys in
this business and I'm so happy for all
you success uh his uh his new special is
bite the bullet on Amazon Prime he has a
new terrorizing telemarketers volume 17
18 minutes and one second yeah a track
called fiance if you listen to anything
just go to fiance wherever you listen to
music and just hear how long you will
talk about uncomfortable it's one of the
saddest It's just sad the track it's sad
and evil is what it is well I do love
that the guy actually finally did
because a lot of times like you you
would do [ __ ] and the guy still tries to
make the sale like he would act like you
had like mental issues oh yeah yeah I
was drowning my grandma my grandfather
in the tub because I was giving him a
bath one time and he wouldn't shut up as
the woman's giving me information I
stick him under the water and I drown
him and she's not breathing she's like
well you better call 9-1-1 I go what's
the information real quick so I want to
get this she goes right back into a
pitch it's great I used to do
telemarketing and I would have been one
of those people that goes back to the
pitch uh the great Jim Florentine
everybody please enjoy the music coming
up next pick by the wonderful Andrew
femalis and we'll have a bonus episode
of the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast have a
great weekend you [ __ ]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast bet MGM NFL
preview Edition going into week number
four but before we get started we got to
talk about our great sponsor uh our
great app your great app your favorite
gambling app it's the BET MGM app as you
guys know we've teamed up with bet MGM
this season we'll be using bet MGM lines
to make all of our picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up for uh bet
MGM yet what the are you doing uh use
bonus code Burr b-u-r-r and you'll get a
hundred dollars uh I'm sorry a hundred
percent risk free up to a thousand
dollars on your first wager here's how
it works you download the betmgm app
simple enough and you sign up using
bonus code b u r r very simple then
you'll receive a thousand dollars uh in
free bets and if you lose just make sure
you use bonus code uh Burr when you sign
up they're giving you up to uh a
thousand so there you go uh doesn't get
better than that they'll put some uh
they'll put some change in your account
you have a good time
curiosity Paul I don't want to insult
you or your Italian Heritage with this
question but where's the mob in all of
this
but mgm's just muscling in on that
territory and they're just laying back
saying no they got to be getting a piece
of this
hey man hey you know not for nothing
we've been kind of running this game
here since before they had face masks
you know going back to Auto Graham so
you know can I talk to you for a second
it's an easy way to do this and then
there's the other way which you know
who's in charge here can I who's in
charge no no we got sandwiches I just
want to talk you got you you want a
coffee
that's my favorite thing about the mob
is there's always food involved even
when it's a conflict no no sit down
we're gonna go get some remember when
they were gonna at least in Hollywood
there is I wonder how it is in real life
I bet it's not that way I bet it's
[ __ ] scary
um I don't think there's a big band
playing when you go to walk in and get
whacked
I like to do in the Hollywood movies
leave the gun take the cannolis one of
the greatest lines in my history uh
clemenza I believe oh yeah make the
cannolis
um
so I have back to back bad weeks going
um one and three because the New York
Giants offensive line stinks bill goes I
believe two one and one with the tie
with the Bears and we are getting close
how about that Dolphins pick Paul don't
blight that was that was my masterpiece
so far Dolphins pick was it was your met
was your pick so far and Bengals was it
I don't know why I didn't say I didn't
talk more [ __ ] Bengals coming off two
losses
and the Jets won like they're gonna
[ __ ] win two in a row doing what I
was thinking your dolphin's pick was
like when you go for a round of golf and
you hit one like and you go it's the
shot of the day that's the shot of your
season so far uh that's a good it would
have been more impressive if I didn't
you know I pushed on the Bears who knew
the [ __ ] Texans were gonna show up
and then um
Seattle had a chance at the end I didn't
know Marcus Mariota I forgot that he was
the quarterback of the Falcons I still
would have taken Seattle though
um Paul I gotta talk to you I gotta talk
to you about this week though
something that I noticed this week Paul
I noticed when I went to the bed and
when I went to the BET MGM website yeah
you know what I saw Paul a lot of Threes
a lot of ones a lot of threes and a
halfs you know what you got this year
Paul you got parody
a gambler's nightmare
[ __ ] game could go either way this
could be a hard year dude I uh I
actually saw that and I was trying to
look this is like I'm I looked at it uh
before and I'm going I thought what you
thought I go there close and then I was
like there's a lot of games I'm not
touching so I'm thinking I'm wondering
where Bill's going because they're half
these games I want nothing to do know
this Paul I there isn't a game this week
that I go oh yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah I got that one so Vegas is
patting themselves on the back right now
who goes first this week I go first this
week
and uh
wait a minute just real Curious Andrew
so I went three in one one and three and
one and three
oh boy we're ho I'm I'm two under five
one or two under 500 Bill we gotta well
we can't do we gotta beat the book here
I mean as much as we [ __ ] around with
each other this is really about us
making our listeners money and who's
getting who Ari goes
so we can walk all the book yeah you're
worried about him I [ __ ] beat him two
years in a row that's what we want this
is who I'm gonna all right this is my
go-to for the first one all versus
you're coming out of this shoe coming
out strong with a big victory come on
Paul we need some wins they are at home
they they also lost that home last week
at home again good team on the road
coming home after a loss Paul versing
Theory all day no they've been home
though they were home they were home for
the loss in their home again I'm gonna
take time to relax Paul they've been
home for two
okay okay I'm gonna take Tom Brady for
the simple reason that I don't think
he's gonna lose two in a row and I don't
and I've been saying I don't believe in
the Chiefs uh the Colts beat the Chiefs
and I think Brady's gonna beat them too
and that game is minus one so I'm gonna
take the bucks at home with the bounce
back beat Mahomes I liked everything you
just said
I liked everything you just said I'll
tell you what I'm gonna do Paul I don't
know why
I know what you're gonna say I know I'm
taking the Miami Dolphins tonight plus
three and a half
because I just think athletically
they're a better team Bengals are a
little hit and miss they had that big
thing they're both four days off I just
think that the Dolphins are uh just
physically a more Superior athletic team
can I tell you something from the bottom
of my heart
I like that pick
you don't like that [ __ ] well the way
you've been picking I've been picking
them almost as bad as me hey it's only
three weeks it's only three weeks oh
Paul I got a giant goose egg on my
[ __ ] head I already had to wear the
duns hat this year right you know what I
like about that I like that you're
getting the the half a point two three
and a half and you're getting I like
that all right my second pick I believe
in the Detroit Lions and I believe the
Detroit Lions
are going to beat Geno Smith okay in
Detroit okay minus four I think Detroit
has a Breakout game more it's minus four
oh I like minus three minus four minus
four makes old freckles nervous over
here I think Detroit wins this game by
seven or more and they have their
breakout week of the season because
they've been right on the cusp I'm going
Detroit Lions I just like that you've
been paying attention to the Detroit
Lions as you call them
did you hear what their coach said dude
that guy is the best he just goes he
puts the thing down he goes he goes no
no I don't sleep he goes after wins or
losses I don't sleep and dude he meant
it his face he goes no he goes if we win
I don't sleep if we lose I don't sleep
he goes it's it's a quick hour nap it's
back to work planning we just got a plan
I was like that guy if that guy's not
divorced by a week
in Indy
in Indy because I'll tell you I I don't
think Andy you know they won big last
week or whatever I don't think I think
they they got their running back still
healthy right
yes still there coach I like that one
that's one of those games everybody's
like oh the Colts are on track Maddie
ice here he comes that's a trap game
right there and guess what I think I
just stepped in it because I'm betting
on the game
that's a ballsy would you do if I just
snorted this violence vitamin C packet
this is what they snort in Portland
Oregon
uh
okay
let's see here
okay my my third pick oh it's getting
Slim Chickens out there Paul
as much as I hate to do this
as much
you pulling a billy red face here you
betting against your own team no no no
no no but but close it's close as much
as I hate to do this the Dallas Cowboys
the Dallas Cowboys are minus three at
home against the commanders I know it's
a division game that backup quarterback
will cause a controversy with Dak and
Mark these words here we got it we got
it uh recorded if the Cowboys win the
next two there's gonna be talks to not
have Dak back and I have friends bill
you know who I'm talking about that are
die hard Cowboy fans that don't like Dak
and love this kid rush but they looked
really good man and they they their
defensive line ran through ours I'm
gonna take the Cowboys minus three at
home
coming off that Giants win I think the
commanders are going to win that game
outright you do yeah because they
[ __ ] hate each other it's a division
rivalry and it makes no [ __ ] sense
because they got this [ __ ] kicked out of
him by the Eagles last week Cowboys
played good this is a trap game that's a
trap game Paul
all right I don't wanna I hate dude I
hate to do that to you I don't know why
I just did that there was a [ __ ] thing
and I'm sorry I'm rooting for you I want
to beat the book here but I was hoping I
was hoping you're gonna go commanders
that's a trap game I think the
commanders win outright I'm rooting for
you though
I am rooting for you I don't want you to
lose but uh all right uh I don't have
the games in front of me here I the next
one that I have that I have on my docket
Paul
is uh
um
come on oh I like this Andrew I love the
graphics this year
we stepped up our game I could look at
it right there bill it's on the screen I
know but how come the [ __ ] game isn't
where I'm looking
um I wanted to find it not somebody else
I'm taking the Pittsburgh Steelers minus
three and a half at home against the
Jets
uh Steelers aren't that good Jets aren't
that good Joe Flacco has experience I'll
probably eat a dick on this one but you
know what just I'll I'll tell you this
and I don't have to but because I'm a
friend and I don't Zach Wilson they're
starters back this week so Flacco's not
in
oh
the type of guy I am let's not forget it
Zach Wilson sounds like he's on the math
team I'm still going with the Pittsburgh
Steelers minus three and a half Zach
okay
every kid that was a spaz when I was a
kid was named Zach
or Seth all right here we go
I'm torn between my last pick but
I think I have to do it dude I might go
one and three I mean this is
it's oh it's a rough one
I'm gonna take
the Los Angeles Chargers
against the Texans the Chargers are
coming off a brutal loss I know their
quarterback was a little banged up with
a rib injury but uh I think that they
can beat the Texans by more than five I
think they will beat them by more than
five I like that bet so I'm gonna take
the I'm gonna take the Los Angeles
Chargers
um minus five on the road at Houston
I like that because last week Houston
showed up
they don't I don't think they got it two
weeks in a row all right Paul I don't
know if you've noticed who's the biggest
Underdog of the week
um
my New England Patriots
oh yeah they are that that I saw that
number is disrespectful in Green Bay
yeah
I know but what's his face Mac Jones is
hurt got a high ankle sprain
I think we go to either Tom Owen or
Scott zolak after that I gotta look at
the depth chart uh I'm going with uh
betting on another division rivalry game
these games are always close so I like
taking the points on those things the
Denver Broncos
who I think now they're going to be four
games with uh with old [ __ ] uh Drake
who's that quarterback again
um
playing the Las Vegas Raiders getting
two and a half I think Derek Carr Derek
Carr not Derek Carr no I'm taking the
Broncos oh uh uh Russell Russell Wilson
well said
um I think he has a Breakout game with
the Broncos
okay
you're nice he's still [ __ ] Russell
Wilson he's driving a new car he's got
to see how it goes into the corners how
it comes out all right yeah the rate is
historically Paul for decades under a
chief
um
and that's why they're not going to you
know
we both we both didn't touch
the game that I I know I looked at but
then I kind of shied away and you didn't
even mention it was
the the Bills lost against the Dolphins
and now their three-point favorites on
the road against the Ravens that's a
tough one
I hate that game that's a tough one dude
I hate that game but you know what I
still have Phantom limb with with uh uh
Ed Reed and and uh
Ray Lewis I just still feel like they're
still there
so I never I always stay away from them
they always play well against the
Patriots
um I respect the Ravens I just feel like
Mike singletary's with the Bears he's
just there he's in the middle
like his The Vapor the vapor from his
career still lingers and people play
better that happens with the Giants
somehow if you play in the Giants you're
just gonna play good D you guys are just
always playing good defense you know you
love picking a random white guy from
some weird [ __ ] College
Phil Sims Eli
Dave [ __ ] ground who's the guy you
know date well Dave Brown was the guy
Brown another Alias you give to the cops
now we have now we have uh Daniel Jones
uh from the from duke has another Alias
sterile they're all Alias names these
are all names you give to the cops when
I was growing up
did you have fun in um Arizona that was
awesome first live one guys we got to do
more of those
oh that's gonna happen you were talking
to uh some people there in Vegas
uh about about going to Vegas possibly I
would love to do that and uh I just had
so much fun and I loved uh I I just
loved doing I just what I love about the
live thing is when you say something
somebody just you see them in the crowd
going they stink oh yeah no
um
want to apologize to everybody for for
for you know what
bill was kind enough to not let me go
against I wouldn't have gone against the
Giants for the Monday night special so
we lost that one saquan did have a
touchdown uh Jim Florentine hit me up
and under did come in
the under came in saquan Ran one and of
course the Giants uh got their uh the
the defensive line of the Cowboys ran
through the Giants offensive line like a
knife through hot butter it made me sick
but I made I made you know I made money
uh Florentine texted me and he goes oh
he this is him in my head is Bursey do
you think uh what did he say he goes uh
the under over 72 saquan gonna go over
and I go he's gonna go over and at the
end he did and and so I was glad to do
that I got 40 on that touchdown run it
felt like yeah he got I think he ended
up with like 78 or something he's still
two overall in in football he's playing
great he's making cuts the Giants
offensive line [ __ ] stinks and you
know what this guy is off the train for
a while until I see a quarterback that
could stand in the pocket for more than
eight plays a game so but guess what
time it is now bill it's time for what
oh let them Monday and that's best show
with some money for you let the Monday
night special
win some [ __ ] money for you it is the
Los Angeles Ram your wife now
because you can spend it on yourself
okay the Raider and a new [ __ ] driver
all right it's the Rams and the San
Francisco 49ers in San Francisco and San
Francisco is minus one and a half
against the Raiders I mean against the
Rams who we saw last week live in person
in Arizona bill this is a tough one one
and a half the under over is 42 and a
half
I hate all of those numbers oh it's
tough
um do the Rams go back to back does does
McVay have them back does the
back-to-back division wins
or who the what the 49ers do last week
they killed somebody last week didn't
they
Andrew you have that score uh 49ers
Jimmy G dude these things all of these
games this week three and a half two and
a half one and a half what the [ __ ]
I'll tell you Paul it's a wide open year
this year
um
Niners it was uh it was 10 to 11.
10 to 11. and who'd they play who'd they
play yeah the Broncos yeah that was the
Sunday night game watch that oh the
Broncos won the Broncos won by one by
one yeah oh there's my homecoming Theory
Jimmy G Jimmy G against that [ __ ]
lunatic number 99
guy's gonna be in his kitchen all
[ __ ] day Paul Cooper cup to get one
that's that's I mean
it's a shirt to get a touchdown yeah
Cooper cop to get one Donald to get a
sack
no they're not gonna let us do that and
Jimmy G to uh make the women all swoon
uh who do you like to win the game I'm
feeling 49ers
it's so for me that's a flip of a coin
I'll go Niners with you you went you
went Giants with me last week I'll go
Niners with you at home
Jimmy G Italian Kid hard for me to lay
off let's do it
I hate this game Paul
I hate this game because I think the
Rams have a better they have a better
quarterback
I like over 42 and a half
I like over it you know what these games
have been real stingy lately Paul I
think one of them's got to go nuts here
I'll take the over
rooting for points what do we do here we
go we can either go over Cooper cup and
Rams or over Koopa cup
that's not easy to say Cooper cup Cooper
cop Cooper cup and uh 49ers
do you want to go Cooper cup touchdown
or Jimmy G throwing one
I don't want to go Jimmy G throwing one
all right so we'll go oh Andrew so we'll
go over
Niners to cover one and a half and
Cooper cup to get one you don't think
the Rams are gonna win that game
they actually have a full-size
quarterback Paul Jimmy G's a little
undersized they have an absolute [ __ ]
future Hall of Famer
with a main streak
yeah but our Arizona are the Cardinals
just not good
that's the thing like the Rams have not
been good until they played Arizona and
the Cardinals have been bad I know but
they also won the Super Bowl last year
and they spent like 90 zillion dollars
on five different players they are
stacked you know it's not cheating Paul
they just found a way around the salary
cap that's all no one ever thought to do
stuff like that so it's not cheating
unless Bill Belichick and Bob crafted it
then they'd be like typical [ __ ]
Patriots
San Francisco hung with the Broncos you
know that there's [ __ ] people out
there Paul as a Patriots fan I'm [ __ ]
sitting there listening to people
defending Sammy Sosa Mark McGuire and
Barry Bonds going everybody cheats you
know the numbers are the numbers
I hate that trying to say that they
count
I hate that I hate that it doesn't count
you know what my son says a white guy
now I mean how much of a [ __ ] have a
steam
he went from juicing to bleaching it was
like you're [ __ ] looking at 66 come
on
Sammy Sosa looks like you were the perm
yeah
um so
so you know what my 13 year old son said
to me my 13 year old son said Dad judge
did it clean no steroids now think about
that if those young kids are feeling
that then they think the cheating sucks
and everybody going I want everybody
yeah he's right but why does why do
people there's a thing about steroids
too yeah steroids you feel like it's the
first game of the year
the whole year
you're coming up there feeling like a
[ __ ] like you're one of those Marvel
guys
with your underwear and the outside as
the joke goes right
by the way I got psyched last night when
judge hit it man but dude they showed
how big he is dude he's six eight he's
two they said he's two inches tall
almost two inches taller than Gronk and
40 pounds heavier
that's like the biggest baseball player
ever that's like I want to say it is I
mean uh
I think the big unit was actually taller
no the Randy Johnson was uh he was uh
610.
oh my God and they said his arm when he
threw it like at home plate it was like
ridiculous like faster because he was so
big
um
it's probably was it 60 feet six inches
he was probably like 58 feet 50. it was
like Bugs Bunny in a cartoon so I just
reached wait a minute how far would that
be if he's it's at 6 10 like it's almost
three and a half feet no ridiculous but
I'm with you dude I'm with you these
guys going let everybody [ __ ] juice I
want to see 400 home runs and I'm I'm
like well like that's just fake it's
like
dude I ran into an Astros fan
oh my God does it take a little bit of
this other Shine off of it he's just
like no no I love it I love it everybody
does it everybody does it everybody does
it all of these [ __ ] [ __ ] Paul for
20 years
with the [ __ ] Patriots from 2007
Spygate on I gotta listen to all these
[ __ ] people like they give a [ __ ]
about about you know [ __ ] cheating
like they give a [ __ ] about any of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] now all of a sudden all of
their teams are doing it nope and this
what kills me yeah nobody has a problem
where's ESPN
nowhere
nowhere my thing is why have records of
the Hall of Fame if it's if it's
manipulated
dude you can't have St that's my thing
okay
out of all the [ __ ] that I've seen
people do cork bats and all of this type
of [ __ ] the number one [ __ ] thing
dude is if you're on performance
enhancing drugs
performance enhancing drugs that that's
it's it's [ __ ] yeah out of
everything else is [ __ ] [ __ ] and
now that [ __ ] crap about stealing
signs and [ __ ] I'm watching college
games and every time a [ __ ] coach is
talking he's doing this they're always
doing this Paul why are they doing that
because there's somebody over there with
binoculars trying to read their lips
which is a skill trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] they're doing Do You Hear
What Aaron Rodgers did Paul did you hear
that do you hear it Aaron Rodgers I just
pictured it up well it's just that when
when put [ __ ]
I just
I'm just beside myself because I really
started to believe that everybody cared
about a fair game yeah but Bill I just
pictured a husband or a father fighting
with his wife talking to his kids and
his wife's like God in here he's going
all right guys
all right don't tell your mother I said
this but she's being an impossible [ __ ]
right now so why are we fighting why are
we playing why are we fighting because
your mother has to be right all the time
she comes first before you guys and
someday when you get older you're gonna
understand how [ __ ] up that is for an
adult to do that God forbid I come home
we're gonna go out to uh we're gonna go
out to the yogurt place
do you want something she always wants
something why the [ __ ] wouldn't she she
probably doesn't even want something she
just likes when I spend my [ __ ] money
all right so Michael's on it got it
who's coming over for Thanksgiving yeah
a bunch of people that she invited that
I don't want there but it's it's the
holidays and I'm gonna get the turkey
yeah I don't mind a cork bat I don't
mind a [ __ ] Apple watch I don't mind
a [ __ ] trash can that shit's all
funny to me I don't give a [ __ ] about
that stealing signs I don't give a [ __ ]
about that but if you're up there dude
and you're [ __ ] like three times the
size you should be and you feel like
you're brand new out of the box and game
[ __ ] 160 it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
agree and the fact that your eyesight
they say is better and it's a game of
hand-eye coordination everything is
sharper your pain goes away oh you rip
something in your elbow no problem yeah
I have no problem with steroids if
everyone does them
but if one guy's doing them and the
other guy isn't and you're breaking the
record as some guy
who did steroids or didn't do steroids I
mean that's it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] I'm with you I'm with you
congratulations to Aaron judge I hope to
God oh God it would be sick I hope to
God they are testing that man every 15
minutes for everything in his system so
then people the internet go oh he's on
this synthetic stuff that they can't
test for you they just like make up [ __ ]
to support their argument because
they're a Giants fan or like a Cubs fan
or something like that come on yeah Met
fans and [ __ ]
um all right everybody so that's the
that's the show that's the same people
if I met them in a bar and I said it was
a patriot fan they would give me [ __ ]
for [ __ ] whatever
it's one of my favorite things ever Paul
because I have dirt on all of their
teams and I eviscerate them and then
they walk away and for some reason I
actually feel like there's some sort of
Victory there even though I never see
him again and none of these none of
these games matter Paul no and you're a
grown man with children yeah
if I could just have the same attitude I
have on the golf course which is I don't
give a [ __ ] about anything oh let's talk
about this for one second before we get
out of here okay because here's the
thing about me I gotta give credit where
credit's due and when I'm impressed I'm
impressed Bill Burr ladies and gentlemen
this man who
talk not I'm not going to say talk [ __ ]
about golf but oh I absolutely did I
said it wasn't a sport well forget that
I'm saying why do you go out whatever
it's dumb blah blah this guy gets into
it a little bit has fun
he's relaxed as can be
the kids keeping his head down he's
hitting the thing down the Fairway he's
having a good time now me on the other
hand I'm relaxed and there was this
[ __ ] three
and then you turn into Mr Hyde no I I
they had this three wood we because well
we obviously don't have our own clubs
they have this three wood and I gotta
bang it and I pick my head up and it
goes and Bill's going dude just he's
telling me what I tell people just relax
everything I hit the thing and then
finally I hit it good yeah it took me
three [ __ ] times in bill goes Paul
Paul what's this energy what's this
energy
is the only place where I become you and
you become me
like I'm literally sitting there I could
you know why I keep my head down Paul
because I don't care where it goes
that's nah but dude you uh oh am I in
the rough dude I got a whole bag full of
balls I'm pretty impressed how you play
golf man you play golf really good for a
a guy that doesn't play golf and just
gets it it was fantastic
I'm very impressed I will tell you uh
golf is fun for four holes and then I
just want it to be over
four you know you're not even nine you
know like I mean if the jokes are flying
around I can go like six it wasn't an
overly hot day come on dude I made you I
made you do two spit takes out on the
course I got you twice oh dude you got
me back you got me I spit all over
myself
I just want a new pair of sunglasses
what I loved is when we were at that
Resort we were like for for a half hour
we were little kids running up a water
slide oh my god dude underrated
underrated water slide no line at a
resort oh my God and then you guys all
went in to get ready and I stood a song
came on and I stood in the middle of the
pool with a pina colada and I just go
five more minutes and Berlin goes I
think we gotta go now I go if I did the
owl I did the owl oh yeah just not
when we when we sat down we were
watching the Dolphins and uh and and the
Bills Dolphins scored a touchdown then
the doll and then the bill scored attack
on the Dolphins came back and answered
and I was [ __ ] with you hitting you
with the napkin doing the sign of the
cross and [ __ ] I said hey Paul
I go the Dolphins are winning today and
you just talk to me and you just go
with total [ __ ] God
[Laughter]
what dude that's your pick of the year
so far that's a good one man the only
thing we [ __ ] up dude was that we then
had to go to the game which was a great
time thanks to the Cardinals and
everything [ __ ] great Stadium
everything I'm just too old man this
shit's too loud for me now but
um oh and I gotta confess dude
oh when we left we ended up at a [ __ ]
cigar bar and they put us in the VIP
room and they had all the games on and
we all felt guilty going like should we
call Paul should we but by the time we
got there it was like and you get out
and get in the car and got over there
the game would have been [ __ ] over
but uh you know what's funny about that
nobody told me they just go yeah I think
they went to say cigar joint nobody gave
me any details now I know why
um oh it because it was that good and
and then we had to go like the second
the game was over we were running out of
there to go to the airport but like you
know I wasn't gonna send a picture
you're all [ __ ] rats no no no we all
care about you that's why we didn't send
any pictures there wasn't enough time
Paul
I wasn't gonna rub it in your face
um fine Ash Cigar
shout out
how about this next time we stay at the
resort with drinks and food and we just
look at TVs and we stand in a pool
no next time we go three days and we
don't have any plans other than we just
we golf every day oh golf every day
coffee oh the whole [ __ ] thing
wait are you coffee every day now
uh yeah
you know I am
I love how you jumped in the coffee
Double Espresso I love how you did you
liked it and you gone out too it just
needs to be I can't do two and I've been
drinking coffee for years no because I
want to know if you know how to make it
oh that's so you don't need a double
espresso I just like a double espresso
I'll tell you I'll tell you a great
coffee I'll tell you a great coffee
story so uh Giannis pop is his father
rests his soul it's like coffee I mean
Greeks love cook that's why they have
Diner joints the coffee is like so he
loved coffee but it always had to be
fresh so you honest would say this story
where he would go to a diner and he
would be very nice and respectful but he
would go and he would call you know
people hun hun is it is it is it fresh
yeah yeah it's fresh and he sipped it
and he just goes hun hun not fresh I
need a fresh pot
because coffee drinkers coffee no coffee
is one of the greatest things you'll
ever taste and and the worst if it's not
done right you know will Noonan in
Boston
you know will new name yeah yeah yo I
think he might hope for he's a Boston
comic Boston guy he just tweeted
something today he goes people in Boston
order coffee like they're giving hostage
demands
hahaha
your way man
no my thing is if you can make an
espresso I'll try the other [ __ ] that
you have this is like I've said it's for
Xbox like pizza
I try your Margarita first if you can do
that then I'll try your other [ __ ] but
I'm not gonna come in there and let you
hide behind your topics and shout out to
Bianco Pizza uh in Arizona because I
heard all this and that hype about it we
got two pies we got the sausage and
onion and we got the margarita and I
gotta tell you something it was
absolutely [ __ ] delicious and they
brought out the fresh mozzarella with
the tomatoes and the and the basil and
the olive oil salt pepper it was
actually really delicious oh my God we
dined like Gods we ate like Gods over
there thank you to uh Bianco and there
you have it everybody there is your NFL
week four preview for the anything
better podcast sponsored by betmgm go to
bed MGM download the app use bonus code
Burr and do a bet of as small as ten
dollars you'll get up to a thousand
dollars in uh free bets even if you lose
just make sure you use bonus code Burr
b-u-r-r we love working with them
they're the best lines out there so
download the app today and Monday night
special Cooper cup touchdown
over 42 and a half
Niners cover
we're taking the Niners oh did we did we
take the Niners
yeah
I hate that game dude
I keep flip-flopping
Andrew make sure you I just think they
got a I think the Niners I think the
Rams got a better quarterback Paul
you want to flip it right now
I'll flip it right now are they gonna
win two Road games in the [ __ ] West
is Jimmy G and them lost a Heartbreaker
by one their home this is a tough one
you want to flip a coin
all right heads to San Francisco tails
is the ramps there you go I love unheard
of
oh first time in first time in Monday
night special history he's got right he
haven't got it tails is Rams
Stills oh
oh it is the rain it is the Rams wow we
just flipped it you know what sucks
somebody that turned it off somebody
that turned the podcast off I hope you
listen the whole way through now we got
Rams plus one and a half over 42 and a
half Cooper cup to get a touchdown did
we just lose all our credibility but it
is no it is I mean it's a pick em all
right it's a one here's the thing no you
had a feeling with Rams during the whole
time and uh you kept talking about the
quarterback and this and that we flipped
a coin just to see and fate said it so
there you go coach and they have a
better team
and listen it's one and a half it's a
[ __ ] it's a it's a flip of a coin
anyway it's on this one maybe this is
what gets us on track so there you go
all right that's it everybody thank you
so much for listening to the podcast
Paul when we golfing again
you tell me bud I loved it
I'm gonna take uh take some short game
lessons
yeah I'm gonna I gotta go to the uh I
gotta go to the range and and hit that
so I don't I don't slow you down the
only time I got a little upset was when
that guy hit that [ __ ] ball while we
were coming off the green no and he was
[ __ ] wrong dude I didn't know he was
supposed to get upset you got so mad I
was like oh which I was like no no real
quick this is what happened I got the
guy with the red shirt we're pulling off
the carts and and our cart is in front
of where the cart path arrows are in
front of the green we finish we wrap up
we put we put our clubs back in the bag
and we start driving off and as we drive
off I hear four and there's neon green
ball flies past the back of our cart
that is that that is anybody who golfs
knows that that guy saw us wrapping up
and leaving you wait dude that was
[ __ ] man I was that wasn't me being
cranky that was me going like dude if
that whacks one up somebody didn't say
anything
what you should have said something
I know we were driving what happened if
you picked his ball up and he just threw
it in the [ __ ] Woods
because I think at the I think at one
point you go dude don't even I think you
were like don't worry because you didn't
know and I'm going no dude that was
[ __ ] up dude I I I I thought about it
afterwards I had a delayed upsetment
about it
dad hits one of us in the head because
this [ __ ] [ __ ] can't wait 30
seconds but whatever
um let me know who's telling [ __ ] jokes
that night Paul I mean does he didn't
understand how important we were yeah he
was probably one of those animals with
tattoos at the pool
all right oh yeah oh my God the white
trash Serengeti
dude that adult pool was made me want to
[ __ ] be the best husband I could
possibly be you don't not want to be
standing in that pool anytime you're at
a resort with kid pool Family Pool and
single pool if you want to see the
biggest [ __ ] y'all go to the single pool
that was just called the adult pool
well I mean yeah I guess yeah it didn't
look like there was a lot of uh
I don't know what was going on you
didn't see a lot of people throwing
children in that pool did you no I was
worried whatever was in that pool was
contagious so I went to the other one
well I hope we don't go I hope I don't
go one and three this week hopefully we
have a bounce back week that's it
everybody enjoy your bets uh bet
responsibly and there you go we'll see
you next time we'll see you next week
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday September 29 2014. how the heck
are you oh that's good you know it's
always great to hear that you're doing
well what are you doing right now on
your Monday morning how are you driving
through the [ __ ] rain
this goddamn windshield wiping right
trying to clear your [ __ ] windshield
so you can see that awful building that
you hate going into
get the urge to just [ __ ] keep
driving right by it you know
what if you don't make that left what if
you don't make that right what if you
just keep going straight
what would happen
what if you took your cell phone you
threw it out the [ __ ] window and you
just kept going and you didn't talk to
anybody
and you just kept driving you got a
credit card on you right you got a debit
card you just keep [ __ ] driving
right up and over the hill
right past that [ __ ] soul-leaten
goddamn place you work at you just kept
[ __ ] going
are you commuting right now I want
somebody to do it throw your cell phone
out the [ __ ] window just keep driving
I want to know how far you get and how
long you can last
before you come back
with your bottom lip quivering because
you realize that you don't know how to
start a fire without a match
you ever think about that you ever think
about how stuck in The Matrix you are as
you drive to work on a [ __ ] Monday
morning
why do I assume that all of you hate
your jobs
maybe you'll love your job
Maybe
you
maybe love it maybe you're like like a
job let me think I'm gonna tell you some
jobs that I think that I would actually
I would actually love I would love uh
being a veterinarian
well I don't know about that
seeing animals in pain but you can get
them out of pain
then you got to deal with the weird
owners I wouldn't mind some pet owners I
would be like the the owners that like
I don't know they never found love
so now they love their cat
it could just be a really sad place
right I think the first thing I would do
if I was a vet would be
[Music]
um
I would try to become some sort of
specialist well I got to enter through
the back of the veterinarian place and I
never had to talk to the owners
you know like I don't want to meet him
you know kind of how like I handle
people who advertise on this podcast I
never talk to any of them and anytime
they [ __ ] complain I just give them
their money back and then that's it but
I ne I never get on the phone with them
my advertising person will call me you
know send me an email and just be like
oh they want to talk to you about your
last read
uh do you have any availabilities this
week and I just say no I don't
what about next week I I don't foresee
myself being available ever
if they didn't like the read I
understand it I mean forget about what I
said derogatory about their product how
about the fact I can't even read their
goddamn copy
you know that alone I just give them a
full refund there you go
one free awful read for you sir
enjoy your goddamn
whatever the [ __ ] it is your soliloquies
whatever the hell you're trying to sell
get your soliloquies here
um
well if it makes you feel better I feel
like doing that sometimes too I feel
like just [ __ ] I don't know what I
feel like doing
lately I've just felt like I don't know
going to Wyoming you know
and talk to them real people that put
them pants on one leg at a [ __ ] time
you know go out there talk to some
homophobic racists
you know that I think their neighbor got
probed by a [ __ ] alien
how about that for a nice change of pace
get out there in the open road
[ __ ] run over something in a rental
car you don't even know what it is just
so far out in the bush you don't even
know what that [ __ ] ammo was
if it wasn't on four [ __ ] legs you
would have thought you hit somebody in a
bushy coat I don't even know what I'm
talking about and you know what I don't
give a [ __ ] because I just have to get
through this thing this week I just
gotta somehow Babble for another goddamn
hour so I can get on with my uh and get
on with my day
uh what can I talk about here
um oh last week I mentioned that I was
going back to Boston
right
going back to Boston for the springtime
um
I was gonna uh go back and go to Derek
Jeter's uh last game at Fenway and uh
what ended up happening was I I ended up
getting busy out here and I you know
this business
Show Business it knows when you're gonna
go do something fun oh wait a minute
he's gonna go do something for himself
right so I didn't go back Friday you
know I just I'm just too [ __ ] busy so
I ended up uh giving the tickets to a
buddy of mine and uh this the day I sent
him out all of a sudden Jeter said he
wasn't playing and I got to admit for
the first time in his entire career I
was upset with the guy I was like now
why the [ __ ] would he do that everybody
went out and spent all that extra money
you know they want to pay their respects
blah blah blah
you wait till everybody buys their
tickets then out of nowhere
I don't think I'm gonna play this game
is
you know I was acting like a fan a
selfish [ __ ] [ __ ] what you want to do
Derek Jeter do what I want you to do and
your career in a way that's convenient
to me I actually was doing that
then I kind of watched the highlight of
the Yankee game
when he hit the walk-off right and I was
just like yeah
that's the way it should end
why was I getting mad at him
that's exactly the way it should have
ended kind of like Jordan you hit that
last second shot granted it was for a
championship that's how it should have
ended
he shouldn't have come back and played
for the [ __ ] what was it
right and people were saying out Ted
Williams hit that walk-off home run for
the Red Sox and then he sat out the last
three games of the road trip
so I guess he had a right to do that but
you know what he ended up coming up
anyways I didn't even pay attention to
it I uh I watched a little clip of it on
the internet his last um
his last hit he got a RBI Choppa
over the third baseman he was playing in
so I guess there was a runner in scoring
position the runner scored he got an RBI
against the Red Sox I guess they gave
him a nice Ovation and all that type of
[ __ ]
and uh I don't know once he's once I
read that he was tired all the media and
all of that type of crap it's just like
you know what [ __ ] that this guy's been
in the public eye for 20 goddamn years
okay he doesn't know anybody anything if
he he wants to blow off the last couple
games [ __ ] it you know so
whatever I'm actually oddly sad and
Melancholy that that guy's career is
over actually looked at Wikipedia to see
if it already said Derek Jeter was a
professional football player fortunately
it didn't
still said is a professional baseball
player because I guess he hasn't put in
his retirement papers yet do you file
those afterwards I have no idea
but um
I don't know
but as [ __ ] as I was for those like 24
hours when he said he might not play
um
nobody could top the neediness of Keith
Olbermann this week
the way he [ __ ] uh finessed those
stats
I've never seen a guy so desperate for
[ __ ] love and acceptance in my life
all I heard after like the first [ __ ]
minute of that
Keith oberman's [ __ ] was this was a guy
he want he wants everybody to say about
him what they're saying about Derek
Jeter and it's just like dude you're not
that guy
all right
you had [ __ ] ice cold parents they
didn't hug you so now you don't even
know how to accept the love that you
want so you push it away that's why
you're getting fired every [ __ ] six
weeks
that's why you go on TV and you say
stupid things like Mr President shut
your mouth
[Laughter]
oh my God that guy redefines horse's ass
I can't believe anybody even watches
that he comes off like a [ __ ] cartoon
character
he would part of his criticism of Derek
Jeter was he said he won four
championships at the in his first five
years right this is part of his
criticism that he won four championships
his first five years he goes how many
did he win the last 14 years he only won
one
oh what a piece of [ __ ]
he only won five and you know what
actually that was great criticism by
Keith olberman because a lot of people
don't realize that not only did Derek
Jeter play shortstop for the New York
Yankees he also was their GM and he um
he made all those decisions
to sign the Kevin Browns to sign that
200 million dollar [ __ ] Albatross
that's been hanging around that neck
Alex
Rodriguez A-Rod right now though those
were all Derek's [ __ ] decisions
give me a [ __ ] break that was one of
the um
I don't know it was pathetic it was
actually he came off like a manager of a
wrestler and he was trying to sell a
fight so he was just arguing the other
side he was pulling like a Skip Bayless
Bayless I couldn't even I've almost
forgot his name halfway through it you
ever do that you start to forget the
name but you know it begins with a b and
you just go with it rewind what I just
said listen how I said Bayless I could
never do that again
um male Bayless
um
yeah like that guy I don't know I just
completely lost my [ __ ] train of
thought now
um
oh yeah he completely forgot to bring up
that the guy had 3 400 hits forgot to
bring all of that up
it was just uh
oh and then he did that really [ __ ]
uh taken out of context cheesy [ __ ]
thing where the he goes you know Derek
Jeter is not the greatest Yankee of all
time
blah blah blah blah and then they
[ __ ] show Jorge Posada saying that
he's the best
you know it's it's his teammate what do
you think he's gonna say
you know if they actually asked Jorge
but do you think that he's [ __ ] you
know
do you honestly think that he's better
than Babe Ruth and Lou Gehrig and all
that he would obviously say look
you know at least I would think he would
he would just say he belongs
in the same sentences as those guys and
I wouldn't argue that
you know I used to think that Derek
Jeter was overrated
you know before I moved to New York and
then once I went to New York and I
started watching him rooting against the
Yankees every night and I saw all that
other [ __ ] that he did
three-game losing streak they finally
get a rally somebody gets a hit
and the guy scores who's the first guy
at the top of the Step In The Dugout the
[ __ ] captain
all that [ __ ] that a guy like Keith
olberman who's not a [ __ ] team player
Mr President shot your mouth who the
[ __ ] would ever have the [ __ ] balls
to go on television
and reprimand the president
you know
sitting there talking like you're in the
Pentagon
I swear to God some people you know you
give them a little gel in their hair you
give them a suit and put a camera on
them all of a sudden they they think
they know [ __ ]
um so anyways he was either he was he he
can't speak he was either doing that or
he was just [ __ ] uh
he was just being a contrarian just to
get some ratings because I never watched
that guy's show
they just don't yeah what was the most
amazing thing about Keith uh Overman is
how big he is I remember when he went on
Letterman Letterman said it like you are
a large man like he just is [ __ ]
gigantic
like he could have played
he's like a [ __ ] refrigerator with a
head on it
um but I haven't said all that you know
I gotta tell you from Keith olberman I
got to be wondering why I said all that
[ __ ] about Derek Jeter
um
hey you know it was great this week no
no no no no uh no Ray Rice [ __ ]
I didn't watch any pregame but I didn't
hear anything about it which is great
that that died down just in time for a
month of that pink horseshit coming up
already started to see it some [ __ ]
bottle pink lemonade just in case you
forgot in the last 11 months there's
something out there called breast cancer
and it's a bad thing we need to find a
carrot just in case you forgot that it
exists
we're gonna paint everything pink this
month
all right
we're going to tell those children in
the sweatshops in El Salvador that when
they make the pink [ __ ] for the NFL make
it extra pink this year just in case
anybody forgets
um oh Jesus I thought I was going to be
in a good mood this week I'm like extra
[ __ ] here did you guys watch any any of
the uh the NFL football I um I did my
usual I told you my new thing I watched
the early game and I tape another one I
watch the four o'clock game and I tape
another four o'clock game and then I
tape the Sunday night game and then I
watched the one one o'clock one four
o'clock then I watched the Monday night
game and then Tuesday I watched the one
o'clock game Wednesday I watched the
four o'clock game Thursday I watch
Thursday Night Football Friday I watch
Sunday Night Football and then say I
watch the college football it's [ __ ]
brilliant I can't believe how many years
I had a [ __ ] DVR before I figured out
to do that
it's perfect
so
this is what I watched this week I
watched the Jets versus the Lions
and I taped the Packers versus the Bears
and then I I know what you're thinking
Bill why the [ __ ]
why didn't you just tape the [ __ ]
Jets game and actually watch the Bears
Packers one of the oldest rivalries in
the National Football League why didn't
you do that
and it's because you know Patriots are
in the AFC East and I just wanted to see
how we would match up against the Jets
I've watched them two weeks in a row I
think we're going to have a we're going
to have trouble with them
because uh I don't know we had trouble
with the Raiders
we lost to the Dolphins we had trouble
with the Raiders the Dolphins pounded
the [ __ ] Raiders now I know this is
just all horseshit it's just the first
month of the season
but it definitely uh
I don't know I'm not feeling too
confident about the [ __ ] team
and um
I don't know Rex Ryan is one in three
now
one and three
and uh
I don't know I was talking to Versi
versy's picking the Eagles and the Colts
to be in the Super Bowl this year
and uh I have no idea everybody just
kind of
see how to blew me away the first week
so did the 49ers and now both of them
are looking kind of I'm not saying
they're bad but they don't look
unbeatable
and um
I don't know 49ers look [ __ ] terrible
today
as did the uh
what the [ __ ] Jesus Christ I watched so
many [ __ ] games who the hell were
they playing they beat the Eagles the
eagles look terrible today
[ __ ] Terror was like nobody wanted to
win the game I'm like these are two of
the elite teams
in in in the [ __ ] League I mean how
many times
49ers taking all those penalties
Kaepernick
they got a giant clock you see the play
clock the [ __ ] guy lets it run down
like two three times during the game
I don't know
I don't [ __ ] you know something the
Eagles are the Eagles
I don't believe in that coach and I
don't believe in that quarterback I just
don't he just doesn't seem like a uh you
know if he goes down who do you got you
got Mark Sanchez
all right
who used to be a jet so he's got that
curse on him and then he went to the
[ __ ] Eagles who did [ __ ] Mark
Sanchez
piss off
that he goes to the two [ __ ] most
cursed goddamn teams in the NFL both in
green
well that's a good thing he went from
the Jets to the [ __ ] uh
Eagles I guess the only good thing about
that trade is he didn't have to buy some
new boxes
[Music]
I know
I know I'm talking a lot of [ __ ] this
week and as you can tell I don't know
any of the players names
anytime I watch the Jets all I watch uh
depression [ __ ] Ferguson that's all
the only guy I watched I just watched a
man handle somebody
on the outside of the line there and
other than that I'm just I don't know
I always get a little bored with
football by the end of September because
I just absolutely [ __ ] OD on it
and uh but then what the Cure is is now
they're going to dress them up like a
bunch of new you know newborn baby girls
for the next month
and um
you know which of course is gonna just
[ __ ] annoy the [ __ ] out of me
I you know this infiltration of the NFL
with all of this [ __ ] I'm telling you
they're gonna they're just they're
they're gradually women are gradually
going to take over the NFL this is my
prediction where Paul verzi predicts
Super Bowl winners I like to predict
random [ __ ] like my prediction to Paul
is that Rex Ryan is going to have an
altercation with the fan this year I
don't think physical I think he's gonna
he's he's gonna have a [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
fight that is gonna be caught on camera
either as he walks out of a stadium his
or somebody else's
or it's going to be outside like a
Hooters or a Waffle House
all depends
um
okay one and three
you know the Heat's getting turned up
and and he is uh that guy's wired
he's got a short fuse okay and I can
relate to that so I know he he's people
are going to start saying [ __ ] to him
and he is gonna [ __ ] snap because
that's the way he's wired and I don't
wish it on the guy but uh whatever he
says is gonna be [ __ ] great and
probably put on a t-shirt I don't know
if that's gonna happen but I'm
predicting that that's one of my that's
my first prediction for this year if you
just want who's gonna [ __ ] you know
lead the league in rushing you go listen
to the Versi effect all right if you
want to hear the [ __ ]
I don't know Flying Saucer Illuminati
[ __ ] you listen to this one
all right and if something comes in I'll
say I got lucky
that's the difference right now between
me a goddamn gentleman and that [ __ ]
animal from New Jersey Paul verzi
now listen to the Virgin effect he
actually he's pretty good at picking a
Super Bowl guy Super Bowl guy Super Bowl
team all right so here we go
that's my first prediction Rex Ryan is
going to have an altercation with the
fan
uh that is going to get him fined
or at the very least put on TMZ all
right number two my next prediction is
over the next 10 years women will
infiltrate infiltrate the NFL
to the point that
um
they're gonna [ __ ] ruin it
they're gonna ruin it I don't understand
why
they have to be a part of it
is this sexist I don't unders I don't
get it
it's a men's football league
can we just have one thing
that gradually creeping in they got the
whole month of October
with the [ __ ] uh with the pink stuff
they got that and now now they got the
ladies they got them down on the
sidelines
they got to go down to them every
[ __ ] 10 minutes check in on them
what do you think there Ethel well he
they saying it's a high ankle sprain and
he's whising in pain and he cannot put
any weight on it
that's all I got down here the
satellites thank you very much Felicia
oh geez you does a wonderful job
um and then eventually they're gonna be
like well why can't we be in the booth
then they'll be in the booth
why can't there be an old female
commentating team then there'll be two
of them
and then it's then the Escape is gone
the Escape is gone what what you know
what a healthy relationship is is a is
is you got to have time away from each
other so you miss each other
you gotta [ __ ] off the ladies they got
late women have to be able to take off
go have a [ __ ] glass of wine
with all their girlfriends and then just
talk about how lousy in bed you are they
need that
so then they can come back and just
[ __ ] deal with you for the next six
days they have to have that and and that
you know guys are no different
why don't women start their own football
league
why are they why are they
I'm gonna get so much [ __ ] for this why
don't why do they keep [ __ ] bellying
up to our bar
you know [ __ ] beat it
look you know I'm [ __ ] half joking
here I'm only half joking
um
do you know how bad
I would love to somehow
get in a room full of feminists without
them knowing that I was a stand-up
comedy and go on go on a panel
all right with like those black frame
glasses and just start saying over the
top ridiculous [ __ ] like I just said
right
and just just see how mad I could make
them
oh God those are the things I fantasize
about like if I had the ability
like one of those [ __ ] who those
[ __ ] nerds that nobody understands
and they can make fire and ice
you know they make they made like 20
movies Halle Berry's in it she has all
white hair
the [ __ ] the mutants there nobody
understands us
it's a it's a [ __ ] metaphor for nerds
and racism I got it
Jesus Christ just get on with the karate
what the [ __ ] are they called
not The Impossibles
oh my God I have no short-term memory
I keep thinking the Fantastic Four like
for some reason I keep picturing them
all in blue what are they called
The Expendables The Impossibles
the mutants
now it'll come to me
whatever you know what I'm talking about
and then the guy from Star Trek is one
of the guys and he's in a wheelchair
oh my God what the [ __ ] are they called
begins with an i doesn't it invincible
whatever I don't [ __ ] know I don't
remember my Goddamn point was
this is this is this is why I'm a
comedian like this right can you imagine
if I actually had a responsible job
the [ __ ] was I talking about I was
talking about women
pissing them off
oh then I said black frame glasses and
then that made me thinking of that
[ __ ] Rex Reed guy who's actually a
critic on The Gong Show
he's not the Fantastic Four guy
but his last name his name was Reed
wasn't it
oh [ __ ] no speaking of reeds
I went to Griffith Park the other day
every once in a while I'll drive all the
way over there and uh there was this
Asian couple
and one had a clarinet and another one
had a saxophone
and the woman with the clarinet was
killing it
and she was standing about 20 feet away
from her husband who was blowing [ __ ]
clams
all right
[ __ ] clamps
and uh it was [ __ ] hilarious to me
because
I don't know if he was just out of
practice or whatever but it just cracked
me up that she was walking away from him
because she was playing so nicely I can
only imagine how like the fact that
she's actually a musician how bad his
playing must have sound to her
Pitch Perfect [ __ ] ears
but she loved the guy
this is I'm just assuming all this but
she loves the guys so she [ __ ]
tolerates it but she she just steps away
a little bit
you know
[ __ ] you I know none of that made sense
but you know what you play a clarinet
with a reed
okay
I don't know saxophone do you got a
mouthpiece
all I know is after you play a while you
got to blow out the spit all right let
me uh let me do a little advertising
here
Jesus Christ I got The Yips
I was doing great there for a minute I
was doing great there
all right let's get back to what the
hell I wanted to talk about
um
how far into this are we 30 minutes
30 minutes so uh what did I do this week
nothing I just did more writing more
writing more writing more writing and
this weekend I have um
what do I got I have uh Davis Symphony
Hall October 4th we added a second show
how great is that I am excited and um
we're gonna uh
I don't know I'm gonna do stand-up all
this week
I'm gonna tighten up everything that I
want to tighten up and this is my first
road gig in a while and uh I'm putting a
little bit of pressure on myself
um San Francisco is a unbelievable
comedy town for whatever reason
who knows why they are a great comedy
town you never know why why one Town's
gonna be better than the other but
they're one of the best out there so I
can't go up there and suck
because those bergenstocked hippies no
comedy up there
I always like going to San Francisco
because it's that weird sort of
cross-section of people right
you got the hey man from [ __ ] San
Francisco and then you got the absolute
animals coming in from [ __ ] Oakland
you know and then you put them all
together you add alcohol and it's it's a
fun show
everybody gets a chance
um I don't know what I'm talking about
at this point so anyways yeah I didn't
go back to Boston and I stayed out here
and uh
worked on this [ __ ] thing I'm trying
to get on on the ground off the ground I
should say uh played a little bit of
drums
that's all I can tell you I'm still
[ __ ] with that double pedal still
struggling along I'm gonna stick with it
um you know what [ __ ] this let's just
get to the questions for this week and
uh maybe this will this will this will
spur something on here uh gambling
problem
uh dear Billy Betts I gotta so Billy
bats I like it I like it he has a
gambling problem I get it I have a
gambling problem not the kind you think
I've always enjoyed a bet here and there
but never made a life of it in the last
few years I've developed this anxious
twitch
oh Jesus
um I think about what I would bet on and
worry about my hypothetical bet the
entire game it's nuts should I just
place a small bet every now and then to
scratch this itch the thing is I don't
like gambling it's the thought that
scares me
what
so their reverse might be like back in
the day when your old man made you smoke
a pack to break the Habit thoughts oh I
see
um
no I wouldn't Gamble dude if you're
already twitching like Fred Flintstone
bad bad bad bad bad
anybody almost 50 and remembers that
episode bad bad bad bad bad
Fred Flintstone started gambling and he
had a [ __ ] problem with gambling and
they didn't have Gamblers Anonymous yet
because they made those episodes in like
the [ __ ] early 60s I think and
um
when Fred Fred started get spinning out
of control
you know if anybody just said like hey
you want to put a bet on that he would
just his eyes would start spinning he'd
go bad bad bad bad bad like freaking the
[ __ ] out it was weird like he had this
unbelievable gambling problem for one
episode and then it all went away
it all [ __ ] went away
um and that's you know something I've
given you guys more goddamn history
about the Fred Flintstone show
you know when you really think about it
if you continue to listen to this this
if you go back I should say or if you've
been listening to it continuously I
think that that's what I was trying to
say I told you how it was based on I
think they they ripped off The
Honeymooners
and then they had that one episode where
they were making fun of The Beatles and
Elvis where they were like bug music I
can't stand bug music
and uh whatever happened to that Georgia
Boy I think that was making fun of Elvis
because he had kind of fallen off and he
was from he was from Mississippi
um anyways what am I let's get back to
this guy here uh
dude a few hours obviously if you
already have a nervous twitch about
gambling why like
that's like hey you know I [ __ ] sit
around and fantasize about killing
somebody should I go out and just kill
one person just so I kind of get it out
of my system
no I think you should uh
I don't know I don't know what to tell
you
that sounds like you need some new age
[ __ ] you know you could go get
hypnotized or something
um but I would not start gambling doing
gambling is just it's [ __ ] brutal
um
gamble you know what it is about
gambling like it really
uh
it takes your soul in a different way
um
then say like drugs and alcohol do or
they like physically
you know change your appearance and all
that type of stuff you know you get the
Gin Blossom nose or if you're doing
harder drugs and stuff you get emaciated
or if you're doing [ __ ] you know what is
that [ __ ] that they do out there in them
crystal meth
you know
you start looking like like the
Petrified version of yourself
um gambling is just a uh
I don't know I had a couple friends that
really had an issue with that and that
was just a Darkness
that was just over them at all times and
you went into their place where they
lived and you just felt it you just felt
the [ __ ] uh
yeah yeah so dude you consider yourself
lucky that you never do and if the worst
you ever do is not Gamble and just sit
there twitching
um
you got off easy believe me
um
yeah let's leave it at that all right
Rex Ryan I'm actually looking it up
right now Rex Ryan
I'm gonna see if they're already calling
for his job the New York media you know
Rex Ryan
New York Post let's see what we get
let's see what we get here
I don't get nothing yet no I probably
looked up the wrong thing I'm the
[ __ ] worst when it comes to this [ __ ]
New York's Post sports here we go hey do
you guys think Derek Jeter will go into
uh broadcasting I don't think he's going
to I think he's going to [ __ ] Fade
Away in a cool way
like uh
oh [ __ ] struggling Gino screams [ __ ] you
at a fan after Jets fall to the Lions
[ __ ] the wrong guy
dude I almost called it
cheetah puts fitting Kappa on brilliant
career
Ready or Not Here Comes A-Rod ah my
favorite Yankee of all time
oh my God
greatest thing that ever happened
was Alex Rodriguez going to the [ __ ]
Yankees let's see if they got anything
Jets
uh um
gang pilot must be bleeping act together
report card Jets having D problems
oh
Red Sox learned from Mariano Fiasco give
Jeter a proper tribute oh did we not
give him the right send-off
go what the [ __ ] it's [ __ ] give me a
break
we're supposed to give all of them a
send-off are you guys going to give Big
Papi your [ __ ] big time send-off
Jesus Christ [ __ ] whining New York
media bunch of goddamn broads all right
let's get back yeah you know you learned
something with that bad [ __ ]
Tupperware party that you threw Mariano
Rivera
well you know what
thanks to Mariano Rivera we [ __ ]
blowing that goddamn game we had the
greatest comeback in [ __ ] baseball
history down three games to none
all right we gave him his tribute the
next year when we were getting our rings
and we gave him that big ovation
ah God you know something that's one
thing I don't miss about living in New
York is that petty [ __ ] they always
think that like Boston has issues with
New York you know which we definitely do
but they got issues with us so [ __ ]
it's kind of even there
like when we finally won a World Series
those [ __ ] actually made a t-shirt
that said 26 to six like we have 26
championships to your sixth that's how
[ __ ] childish they were
at the [ __ ] 86 years of rubbing our
faces in it they were going to have one
rough winner
right couldn't take it had immediately
oh we got 26 of them
oh was that a disgraceful moment in your
[ __ ] history
um all right Syria
dear General Bill need your thoughts is
Isis horseshit
I mean we know we gave them weapons but
they're still but they're still had to
had and need
Jesus Christ guys I can't read and then
you you [ __ ] leave out words in the
sentence I mean we know we gave them
weapons but they are still had and need
to be stopped
people please try to proofread this [ __ ]
but we're not good at stopping anything
in that region your president and in
command what is the move
yeah the mood is we pull out
very slowly
this is what we do
this is what we do the only reason why
any of those [ __ ] have any [ __ ]
money is because Nations like us are
still driving gas combustion engines
so this is what I would do I would try
to jump start more uh
car companies over here like the Tesla
company try to get GM and all those
other [ __ ] to do the same thing and
then we just don't need them anymore and
wean ourselves off of oil and then they
would just slowly go bankrupt the entire
Middle East their entire [ __ ] economy
as far as my complete lack of research
goes is based on the fact that they're
sitting on top of oil so if we just if
we don't need it anymore
what are they going to do
and then they are free to solve their
problems themselves which they should be
doing
um
and as far as you saying we're not good
at stopping anything in that region uh
there's a reason for that there's a
reason why Russia goes into Afghanistan
and Lou and and loses
there's a reason why people go into that
the reason why we went to Vietnam and
lost the only way an occupation works
and this is brutally honest is if you go
in there
and a you're you you're not leaving
okay and B you commit genocide that's
the only way it [ __ ] works that's the
only way it has ever [ __ ] worked and
it is a hundred percent the wrong thing
to [ __ ] do you can't do that so uh
so that's it you know so it's just
inevitable they know eventually you're
going home so all they do is go all
right you beat us you beat us and then
you walk around standing over there and
they just sit there picking you off
making your life [ __ ] miserable and
then eventually like what the [ __ ] are
we doing here let's get out of here and
then you leave
and then they go back to doing whatever
whatever it is that they were doing
anyways but I don't think that we're
going to solve anything over there and I
base that on
Czechoslovakia and Yugoslavia
I didn't have any idea about
any of that [ __ ] serbs and [ __ ]
croatians and all of that I hadn't I
don't and I still don't quite understand
it
that [ __ ] was not going on when I was
born there was already Czechoslovakia
and there was Yugoslavia and all that
type of [ __ ] going on over there and uh
they all had a common enemy in the uh
with the occupation of the Russians in
their country so they were against them
and
when uh Russia fell whatever the [ __ ]
that was like 20 years ago all of a
sudden they got their freedom and they
immediately picked up this fight for
that had stopped like I don't know 60 70
80 100 [ __ ] years earlier and they
started killing each other again
um
you know so I mean you're not gonna
it's over
you'd have a better chance at getting
Ohio State in in the University of
Michigan to like each other then you
will have in all those groups over there
will get along they're not going to get
along
and um
that's just the way it is so that's what
I would do I would just [ __ ]
I would do a bunch of [ __ ] that would
get me whacked way before I would ever
uh achieve it that's what I would do
you know
it's basically it
wasn't that funny Jesus Christ this is
becoming too serious here all right
let's maybe maybe this is a a uh maybe
this is a nicer one Commish dear Bill
you're the commissioner of the NFL ah
[ __ ] here we go again
what are the top three things you're
doing to improve the League this this
can include anything from scheduling to
punishments to campaigning to relocate a
team what would you do
oh Jesus Christ I don't want this
[ __ ] job
one of the top three things I would do
to improve the league
um
I'd get Tony saragusa a [ __ ] chair
you know
didn't he give enough
this guy's got a [ __ ] stand up the
whole goddamn game with his back to
those animals in the end zone that's
what I would do I would give him a nice
[ __ ] End Zone seat
and a water cannon
to [ __ ] spray at all the animals
behind him that's the first thing I
would do next thing I would do is I
would move the kickoffs back
to where they used to kick off or I
would just eliminate that useless
exercise to begin with
and uh number three I would call
somebody in the MLB and I'd get rid of
the DH rule that's what I would do those
are the three things that I would do to
make football better
foreign
I would I would change um
most of the the new rules in passing I
would change it back
I would uh I'd like to know helmet to
helmet I really like that rule
I saw a guy diving for a ball and it was
past his outstretched fingers and he
couldn't catch it and this guy back in
the day it would have been helmet to
helmet would have coming in
perpendicular would have knocked this
guy out and probably hurt himself in the
process too a little bit down the road
30 years later when he was done right
um
and the guy LED with his shoulder hit
the guy in his chest definitely [ __ ]
brutal hit but they both got up and were
fine and they didn't [ __ ] rattle
their brains too bad you know I'm sure
your brain still moves around but I do
like that rule but um
I don't know I I don't know what the
[ __ ] I would do
I had a [ __ ] know I get Tony saragusa
[ __ ] chair and then I would step down
and just say my work is done
would that be okay
I would you know what I would do I would
eliminate
um the expression uh get it right
I would eliminate that because it makes
everybody sound stupid
you know we got to get it right we
didn't get it right next time we're
going to get it right get it right
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I mean that's like [ __ ] like
cavemen
could come up with a better song
all right
just [ __ ] not saying anything that
drives me I [ __ ] hate that expression
get it right all right let's move on to
the next one Jesus Christ this is just
scatterbrain this week all right can't
get laid
uh Bill I'm a huge fan I listen to all
your podcasts and stand up now that I'm
done sucking your dick I love how you
guys just can't give me a [ __ ]
compliment and then you feel all
uncomfortable because you actually enjoy
the comp the [ __ ] podcast just be a
man and give me a goddamn compliment
you know it does suck in your dick
you're uncomfortable I'm not
uncomfortable I enjoy the praise he says
I need some advice I'm starting my
sophomore year of college and I've never
been more depressed my high school
girlfriend broke up with me shortly
after graduation and I haven't gotten
laid since uh it's not like I stay in my
room all day I have friends and I go to
parties at least once a week and even
though I never enjoy even though I never
enjoy myself I just can't get a girl to
be interested in me I also have no idea
what I want to do after college and so I
have no motivation to apply myself the
only reason I haven't dropped out is
because my parents who are paying
thousands and thousands of dollars uh I
don't drop out so they won't be
disappointed I work out every day and I
try to stay busy but most of the time I
just feel terrible I'm hoping you have
some advice for me if not go [ __ ]
yourself and if you do thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself all right
um you obviously have a sense of humor
um
what would my advice be uh you know what
I think you're trying too hard
all right there's no reason to to go to
a party and not have a good time
just go there and enjoy yourself don't
worry about talking to women don't worry
about trying to get laid just have a
good time
just enjoy yourself just go out in life
and just [ __ ]
enjoy yourself okay people are
attractive to positive energy and
somebody having a good time it makes
them want to be around you and next
thing you know somebody's blowing you I
don't understand why the universe works
that way but it does I know I am overly
simplifying this
but um
you know it's good that you know that
you're depressed I was depressed for
about 20 years and didn't realize it
because I was so used to feeling that
way I thought it was just the normal
you know just a normal state of things
um I got to tell you this dude you are
going to get a girlfriend and you're
gonna find love and you're gonna get
married okay but I gotta tell you
there's a [ __ ] misery that comes to
that life
all right there's a great thing but
there's also a misery and she feels it
[ __ ] too and that's a part of you
you're the individual you dies so right
now dude you are the 40 year old you is
gonna look back at the [ __ ] if the 40
year old you could get in a time machine
and sit down with you right now and give
you a [ __ ] pregame speech before you
went to that party
I mean that would be like Scared
Straight he'd be right in your face
you know you have any idea
what it's like to get up at five in the
morning to change a shitty diaper you
get to sleep 10 hours a [ __ ] day you
can't put a smile on your face when you
go to a [ __ ] party single you could
[ __ ] anything that walks
you go down to that 7-Eleven look at me
you go down on that 7-Eleven you get
yourself a box of [ __ ] condoms you
stick them or you stick one in your
pocket
prepare for success
you are in your goddamn shirt you get
down there you have a good [ __ ] time
all right you're only going to be this
age once
he says something like that all right
I'm telling you you're only going to be
this age once you're in college dude you
are at like you're it's like you won the
NBA draft lottery
women there are in the prime of their
[ __ ] life
most of them are [ __ ] single
it's gonna happen for you but if you're
walking around and you're depressed and
you're carrying that with you if you're
moping around like that that makes
people [ __ ] you know
not want to be around you so I would say
drinking is probably not a good thing
because that is a depressant so scratch
that I can't remember if I [ __ ] told
you to to have a couple of beers I
wouldn't do that I would just [ __ ]
enjoy yourself
I almost you know what I would do I
would go do some [ __ ] for you
[ __ ] trying to get a girlfriend [ __ ]
trying to get laid [ __ ] all of that just
go out and what do you want to do if you
don't know what you want to do go out
and go try a bunch of different things
and have a good time dude you're single
okay
you don't have to [ __ ] you don't have
to [ __ ] deal with
trying to figure out what's going to
make them happy
okay because as far as I can [ __ ]
tell
there isn't anything that's going to
make them happy for
longer than maybe a day
the amount of [ __ ] that you can do for
him and as you can tell she's a couple
of rooms away the amount of [ __ ] that
you can [ __ ] do for him
and all it does is buy you a couple of
days of happiness is just [ __ ]
baffling and I gotta be honest with you
a lot of women look at it guys and they
think that we're [ __ ] stupid and I
think part of it is because they have
the way their brain works
that multitasking whatever is that [ __ ]
talk that they always say you know that
women can multitask and guys can't well
I would say that generally speaking this
is very general
I think men
have an advantage when it comes to just
being happy
you know what I mean
like you would know it from my podcast
and the way I talk and [ __ ] but I'm
happy I'm happy as hell and I've been
happy for a long [ __ ] time
you know
all I need to do is all I [ __ ] need
the NFL package
I got a six of [ __ ]
Millers in my in my goddamn refrigerator
you know
I got a new pair of sneakers it's just
some stupid [ __ ] like that I order a
[ __ ] pizza that's all I need I'm
happy the whole [ __ ] day
you know I go on a hike with my dog in
the morning that's it I'm good
simple
stupid [ __ ]
keeps me as a guy entertained I don't
have their high level brain that they're
always talking about their ability I can
do a thousand [ __ ] things yeah and
look at you you're miserable
you're [ __ ] miserable
so
I'm telling you dude you're actually you
don't realize it but where you are right
now dude is you are in an absolute
Utopia do you know how many [ __ ] guys
right now would kill to be in your
position they'd even take two years of
not getting laid who gives a [ __ ]
rub one out get on with your goddamn day
you know get on with your [ __ ] day of
being single not having the answer to
anybody and having the option of hitting
on any beautiful woman that catches your
eye
take a trip anytime you [ __ ] want go
wherever you want to go do whatever the
[ __ ] dude you're never going to get and
your parents are paying for your [ __ ]
education dude you're never going to be
Freer
all right so start looking at your life
that way
and I'm telling you you're gonna have a
different [ __ ] Vibe and I I'm I you
know and I'll tell you right now you
start doing that good things are going
to happen in the National Football
League no I'm serious dude something
good is gonna happen but there will be a
time in your [ __ ] life I'm telling
you where you will be married you'll
have kids and you'll do that whole
[ __ ] thing and that will be its own
sort of utopia
but it's it's
I know dude this is a very it's a
beautiful selfish time in your life that
you should embrace
and you should not uh
you should not spend it feeling bad
about yourself all right so there you go
good luck to you okay
relationship problems
all right bill first of all I would like
to say thank you for all the podcasts
now go [ __ ] yourself there you go that's
how it's done beautiful all right well I
am in my early 20s soon to be the
youngest regional manager in my company
so I kind of feel that I am moving in
the right direction my biggest problem
right now has to be commitment
uh relationship my girlfriend and I have
been together for about six months now
so we are seeing how things work
uh so so we're seeing how things work
right this guy's
must have spoken to his phone
um well lately these things uh things
have not been too great she she
complains about everything if I'm not
home or out with the boys or the gym or
if I don't respond to one simple text
her jealousy is really taking its toll
on me
whenever she sleeps at night she'll talk
for hours on how much she hates work and
just fuss about how I don't do this or
how I how come I do that it's [ __ ]
annoying I have not cheated on this
woman nor have I put myself in any type
of physical situation with her so why
the burden well I hate to add more but
here it is my biggest issue with her it
has to be her son yes her son he is
turning four in a few months but is such
a pain I know he is a child blah blah
blah but this child doesn't know how to
talk use the restroom and think
screaming for everything and throwing a
fit will get what he wants
is this her fault uh yes
this is what this guy says bill I am a
father as well my soon-to-be
five-year-old son is annoyed by this kid
dude you're in your early 20s and you
got a five-year-old son Jesus Christ
um whenever we go out her son tries
to take all my son's toys and then
chooses what he wants to watch and what
he wants and when he wants to leave I
suppose my question to you is should I
simply continue to help her out be with
her slash be with her she is the
breadwinner for her family supporting
her mother who just had a baby and is
unemployed dude is this a Jerry Springer
transcript
and two younger brothers plus her son
financially she's in a hard place so I
help her out when I can I feel guilty
leaving I feel guilty if I left her
right now since I know she's very
attached to this relationship and it may
affect her and I wouldn't want everyone
else to suffer should I say [ __ ] it it's
not worth my unhappiness and my son's
discomfort towards her son or say just
say [ __ ] it write it out until her mom
finds a job or she trains that little
animal of a child right
all right
here's the deal dude
you [ __ ] said something about three
quarters of the way through it first of
all you know with all this stress she
has
in her life supporting all those other
people probably has a lot of the reason
why she's [ __ ] coming at you
uh she's taken out a situation on you in
a little a little way I guess there but
you said
uh
where is it
I feel guilty now since I know she's
very attached
should I say [ __ ] it
it's not worth my unhappiness and my
son's discomfort all right dude so
you're unhappy and your own son is not
comfortable
all right I think that says something
right there
that's what you need to fix right there
you need to be happy and your son needs
to be comfortable or you have to leave
and it's not your fault you know
you know she lives with Carnival people
from your description
all right
um
you got to be selfish in a [ __ ]
relationship when you're single okay and
you're gonna commit to somebody before
you commit with them you got to be
selfish you got to be making sure
at the very least you're being with them
makes you happy uh that sounds like a
[ __ ] nightmare that situation right
there sounds why I waited till I was 45
to get [ __ ] married
um
so I guess what I would say is if you
feel like you could somehow
I mean not leaving not breaking up with
somebody because you feel like it's a
bad time it's never a good [ __ ] time
um all she's doing is getting more and
more attached to you and all you're
doing is taking more and more days away
from her where she could be going out
trying to find somebody else so if uh
that is not a reason to stay so
if you feel like you could try and work
it out you didn't mention once in any of
that that you loved her
so
um
I don't know that sounds about as
miserable a situation
as I can think of
so uh you know but at the end of the day
at the other day it's gonna be your
decision but that relationship is
definitely not firing on all cylinders
and if you're going to stay with this
team you need to create a new culture in
the locker room all right here we go
summertime is over
Bill the circle of seasons is cruel and
beautiful I missed the summer already
but I'll enjoy the fall and the Apple
related feelings
I think I had a fulfilling summer how
are you grading this summer a plus
because Billy got some sun or F because
Bill got some sun
how am I grading this summer
I don't [ __ ] know
I survived it kind of a [ __ ] question
is that that's not even a question
answer the question
um all right
that's it for this week everybody
um I want to thank everybody for the uh
all the tickets sales up there in uh San
Francisco
um I'm really looking forward
you know I need it man I haven't done a
stand-up Road gig in a while and uh I've
been doing that for 22 years and you do
the road as long well
I really started traveling
um seriously doing the road rather than
just driving around doing hell gigs
outside of Boston uh probably been doing
that for like 17 years
right yeah 17 years so
um
you know
it's in my blood man I gotta do it so
the next the next three dates I have
coming up uh Davis Davies kept saying
Davis Davey's Symphony Hall in San
Francisco two shows
this Saturday night October 4th
then I'm doing the spotlight spotlight
casino in Coachella California October
11th and then my next date is at West
Palm Beach Improv on November 14th
because I'm going to a couple of
football games out there
going to the Thursday night game and
then I'm gonna go see uh
the Miami University of Miami
against Florida State
which is hilarious because I'm gonna
have to [ __ ] listen to them doing
that tomahawk chop [ __ ] oh my God
um but anyways
so I don't have a lot of Road dates
because I've been trying to write this
show and then also I'm trying to put
together the new hour before I hit the
road and um so basically if you're
wondering how the next year is shaping
up as I'm finally going to do that
Australian tour then I'm going to do
some Club dates at some of my favorite
stand-up clubs around the country and
get that act ready to go and then I'm
going to do a nice theater tour
and I am hoping to do another European
tour and this time actually add
um
along with the all the countries I did
before I'm going to try to do an Eastern
European leg this time too like
Lithuania Estonia Albania all of that
[ __ ]
um I'm gonna try to uh just see how that
goes
why not right why the [ __ ] not so
um I'm really looking for I'm already
looking forward to the new year
October's coming up right I got to get
my pie crust game together
make my [ __ ] pumpkin bread
you know all [ __ ] purpose flour
uh anyways that's the podcast for this
week everybody I apologize I know it was
a little rocky this week but um if I
didn't do it right now I wouldn't be
able to do it in the morning so uh
anyways what are we gonna do here uh
yeah I didn't get right next week I'm
gonna try to get it right I have no one
to blame for myself and I take full
responsibility that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves and uh
remember my predictions